So dann bin ich, Leute ich hab es geschafft mir beim Essen auf die Backe zu beißen gestern
und das ist jetzt irgendwie ganz rot, ich hab schon so eine Blase jetzt innen an der
Backe, das ist äußerst angenehm, kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sollt ihr auch machen,
gibt nix besseres, heck wait genau, ja also was machen wir heute, ich schwätze heute nicht
rum, ja du kannst dir das sogar schon auf github angucken aber da ist außerdem backhand
noch nicht viel da, wo habe ich mein bonbon hier, sei bei bonbons pock, wisst ihr ich
muss immer schön trinken und bonbons lutschen beim streben das Salz nicht zu kratzig und
trocken und alles wird, oh ja das ist also nicht nur bei Pizza aber Pizza schafft man
es natürlich auch gern weil dann die Tomatensauce schön im Mund hängen bleibt, geht aber bei
anderen Sachen auch, ich hab es mal geschafft das ist schon eine weile her, ähm da hab ich
es geschafft beim, was war das Nudeln, nee, nee nicht Nudeln, ähm Schupfnudeln waren
das, diese dicken, diese dicken Schupfnudeln, so ich hab es mal geschafft vor einer ganzen
weile, ich weiß nicht wie dumm man eigentlich sein kann aber ich hab es mal vor einer ganzen
weile geschafft das zu essen, wenn ich futter wird immer ziemlich schnell gefuttert und
irgendwie hab ich dann, hab ich das gegessen und hab das runtergeschluckt und auf einmal
denke ich mir so, hm wird ganz schön warm im Hals und da hab ich festgestellt ich hab
den Kram nur zur Hälfte runtergeschluckt und das hing quasi noch und es war ziemlich
heiß der Kram, es war quasi frisch, dann hing der Kram quasi noch hinten im Hals und
ich hätte eigentlich mal ordentlich runter schlucken müssen und da hatte ich bestimmt
ne Woche oder so Halsschmerzen, weil ich mir hinten den Hals verbrannt hab mit so ne Nudel
die im Hals hängen geblieben ist, das musst du erstmal schaffen alter, richtig hängen
geblieben, was denn das Wort ist, hängen geblieben, im Hals ist das ja, richtig hängen geblieben
also ich zeige euch mal was wir heute machen Leute, also erstmal machen wir die VM an,
weil unter Windows kann ich nicht mehr programmieren, das krieg ich dann auf die Reihe, dann dreh
ich durch, oh, also, der Titel des Streams heute ist WebEPG für TV Headend, es gibt
ein paar Möglichkeiten wenn man TV Headend verwendet, ja siehste, Family Friendly Stream,
ok das da oben ist glaube ich abgekackt, ach ne, das da oben ist die Cloud VM die ich gelöscht
hab, lul, die kann ich beenden, machen wir das hier auch mal zu, ich mach mal ganz schnell
ein Update und während das updatet zeige ich euch was Sache ist, also, wow, einfach mal
ein Gigabyte Update, Kegweight, also, hier guckt mal, mein TV Headend hab ich euch doch
schon gezeigt, das ist das Ding worüber ich Fernsehsachen aufnehme und streame, so und
die haben EPG Daten für die nächsten 14 Tage, die Sache ist plus die, dieses Web Interface
kann niemand gescheit auf Mobile verwenden und dieses Web Interface kann auch niemand
gescheit auf dem Tablet oder so, dieses Web Interface kannste ja auf dem Desktop nicht
einmal richtig verwenden und wenn man jetzt was programmieren will, gibt es eigentlich
nur so ein paar, ja nicht so schöne Möglichkeiten, Patrick, Moin, 35 Monate Massive Subscription
Alter, huge Subs, ich will meinen Mund nicht betäumen, da bin ich ja dran erinnert, also,
dann gibt es die Möglichkeit für iOS, Android weiß ich nicht, gibt es ein TV Headend App,
da gibt es das hier, wenn man beispielsweise Fernsehprogramme aufnehmen will vom Tablet
aus, wenn man was programmieren will vom Tablet aus, gibt es zum Beispiel das hier,
warum ist der App Store außer auf Mac absichtlich von Apple Scheiße gemacht, warum kann ich
hier keinen Vorschau machen und sowas, das geht im normalen App Store, aber hier geht
es nicht, weil man sich gedacht hat, App Store kann Massive Kacke sein, so, das Ding hat
ein EPG View, das erkennt man aber nicht richtig, aber wenn man ranzoomt, dann funktioniert
das auch, so, diese App hat ein EPG View, der gefällt mir aber nicht wirklich gut und
ich finde den auch nicht schön auf dem Tablet zu bedienen und ich wollte mir sowas hier
selbst machen, von der Idee her ist das gar nicht so schwer, also nicht die komplette App,
nur so ein EPG View will ich mir selbst machen, wo du dann draufklicken kannst und kannst
was programmieren, also ich will da drüber kein Video Playback, wobei wir Video Playback
vielleicht einbauen in Form von einem Link, den ich anklicken kann und wenn ich dann VLC
installiert habe, kann ich den VLC aufmachen oder so, das kann man machen, aber ich will
hauptsächlich eine EPG Übersicht haben, die man gut verwenden kann, wieso machst du
einen neuen Task, so gute Frage, müssen wir uns gleich angucken, Patrick, das Gute ist,
man lernt was dabei und ich verwende den Fernseher eigentlich gar nicht, so gut wie nicht, aber
man kann sich da ein paar schöne Sachen angucken, so in der Richtung was will ich bauen, eigentlich
wo du einfach nur Programme aufnehmen kannst, wo du dann siehst was programmiert ist und
aufnehmen kannst, EPG anklicken, Aufnahme, starten, Aufnahme, stopp, also so, den finde
ich nicht so schön, sondern habe ich mir gedacht wir bauen eine Web Anwendung, weil sowas hier
bietet sich ja nur wirklich richtig an als Web Anwendung zu machen, ich habe auch schon
etwas vorbereitet, damit wir anfangen können, es gibt nämlich auf Github ein Projekt, habe
ich gerade gepusht, den EPG Champ, oh man das Ding schon auf vier Comets, was habe ich
denn da wieder gemacht, ah so Githig neu hinzugefügt, ok, den EPG Champ gepusht, da basteln wir
heute ein bisschen rum, also sowas will ich bauen, die Android App habe ich noch nie getestet,
ich vermute mal die ist ähnlich zur iOS App, also mir persönlich gefällt das nicht und
ich hätte gerne eine Kombination von Desktop View und PWA, das habe ich ja auch hier schon
geschrieben, also wir machen ein modernes Web Interface für den TV Headern EPG und zwar
so, dass es im Desktop Browser funktioniert und dass es mobile als PWA funktioniert, PWA
zu machen, gerade auf iOS ist Panes Champ, aber in dem Fall ist es nicht schlimm, weil
man braucht nur Web Zeugs, also man braucht nichts weitergehendes, ansonsten ist es eklig,
ich habe einen SDR Stick in Billing, so das versuchen wir heute mal, ja am Ende des Streams
werde ich den Kram pushen auf Github, wobei ihr kennt mich, ja, warum kann ich nicht klonen
per SSH, ich muss doch per SSH klonen können, ich bin nicht eingeloggt, das macht doch nichts,
ich muss nicht eingeloggt sein, ich habe meinen SSH Key, ich muss mich nicht einloggen, ich
habe meinen SSH Key, so und jetzt kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Frage im Chat, wieso
machst du bei EPG Updater Service im Execute Async einen neuen Task, das ist eine gute
Frage, keine Ahnung, zeig mal her, warum mache ich das denn, da, hier meinst du, warum
mache ich hier einen neuen Task, das ist eine gute Frage, bin ich mir nicht sicher, weiß
ich nicht, ob das sinnvoll ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, eigentlich unsinnig oder, das müsste
eigentlich auch so funktionieren, so ich zeige euch das jetzt erstmal, also wir checken Repos,
ich mache nochmal Update, ahja, ok, gib ihm, alles updaten, GitHub Codespaces, ich bin
nicht eingeloggt, habe auch keinen Bock mich einzuloggen, Codespaces ist das Web Entwicklungsumgebungszeug
von GitHub, oder, oder ist das sowas wie Codeshare, habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, so sieht
der EPG von Plex aus, ja sowas in der Richtung, so ungefähr, so ungefähr stelle ich mir
die Web App auch vor, so, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich es gerne ein bisschen farbiger machen
würde, weil wir bekommen vom TV Headend die Genres der einzelnen Sendungen, da kann man
beispielsweise News, kann man grün machen und Filme, kann man rot machen oder so, das
müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher, wie man sowas gescheit
implementiert, also was ich mir schwierig vorstelle ist, man muss ja dafür sorgen, dass
die Zeiten gesynkt sind, also sprich, mal angenommen, warum ich mir das gar nicht so
einfach vorstelle, also zum Beispiel, wenn es hier im ersten ein Programm gibt, was
14 Uhr und 1430 losgeht und hier im ZDF gibt es nur eins, was bis dahin geht, ich muss
ja sicherstellen, dass 1430, dass es quasi immer aligned ist, also es reicht nicht, wenn
ich einfach die Events, Hinterländer, Staple pro Sender, dann hast du irgendwann 1430 bei
dem Sender und 0030 bei dem Sender, wenn du das so machst wie in diesem Plexing, ist
das Pain's Jam, weil du ewig scrollen musst, ja aber scrollen geht doch schnell, ich meine,
rüberwischen auf dem Tablet, also ich soll mal sonst machen, ich meine man könnte, man
könnte, gut du kannst hier oben ja auch auswählen, ansonsten wenn du einen guten Vorschlag hast,
wie ist es los, ja, also so sieht es aus, ich werde es in der Richtung, werde ich so
machen, ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, wie ich es hin bekomme, dass die ganzen Programme
richtig aligned sind, also dass sagen wir hier 1530 auf jedem Sender auch 1530 ist,
das heißt ich muss das irgendwie wahrscheinlich anhand Pixel pro Sekunde oder sowas machen,
das ist ja eine ganz neue Einheit, Frames pro Sekunde kennt man, aber Pixel pro Sekunde
ist glaube ich nicht so, ja also ich muss quasi gucken, wie lang ist eine Sendung und
das umrechnen in Pixel und dann halt gucken wieviel Pixel mache ich pro Sekunde Laufzeit
und weil ansonsten ist der Gram nicht gleich lang überall, mach einen DaySale Selector,
wir können hier oben, wir können hier oben so eine, so eine, so eine vorwärts, rückwärts
Knöppe machen, ja, aber das ist gut, Chet wisst ihr was, deswegen mache ich sowas gerne
im Stream, ohne Scheiß, das ist der Grund warum ich sowas gerne im Stream mache, weil
die Leute einfach gute Ideen haben, das finde ich jetzt eine gute Idee, man könnte einfach
sagen Skip to Primetime oder sowas und dann immer, und dann geht der immer zu 20.15,
guckt ihr mal die Waipu-EPG, wie sieht das aus, so, ha, lull, ja so in der Richtung
habe ich mir das vorgestellt, so in der Richtung stelle ich mir das vor, links Logos mit Programm
und rechts einfach die, die Dinger, ja, ja so stelle ich mir das vor, so sieht es ja
bei Cody im Endeffekt auch aus, guckt mal, ich zeige euch mal wie in Cody der EPG aussieht,
ja, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, was, ich glaube ich hab, ha, nee das ist doch richtig, ha,
Hä?!
Ich alles richtig eingestellt.
Ich hab upd-
Ah, vielleicht muss ich does mal neu starten, weil ich geupdated hab.
Kalk, ich rebuild immer schnell.
Bestimmt, weil ich updated hab. Keine Ahnung, woran das liegt.
Vertikal nebeneinander?
Vertikal nebeneinander, also du meinst, dass das nicht nach links nach rechts geht, sondern
dass oben die Sender nebeneinander stehen, da könnte ein Button zum Umschalten machen.
Ja, das hat jemand, irgendjemand hat auch gerade eben im Chat ein Bild gepostet, wie
das bei ihm aussieht.
Das ist für Text Mist, da kommt drauf an wie breit du es machst.
Ok, ich guck mir mal kurz das Bild an, achso, so was kann ich nicht machen, so was kann
ich nicht machen, ich hab ja keine Bilder vom Programm, also ich krieg ja keine Vorschau-Bilder
vom Programm.
Hab ich ja nicht, so, aber so was hier oben kann man zum Beispiel machen, dass man das
man irgendwie so ne Stundenanzeige, ich lass es mal auf, ich find's zur Inspiration ganz
gut, aber gibt's nicht Sprachen wo man von oben nach unten, es gibt auch gerade wo man
von rechts nach links schreibt, ist mir aber egal, so was weirdchampiges support ich nicht,
das ist genauso wie ich keine Kona-Einheiten supporte, bei mir gibt's nur Kilogramm und
Meter und keine Feet und Inches und Zeug.
So, mal gucken ob Cody jetzt wieder angeht, da kann ich euch zeigen wie es dort ausschaut.
So, also, es ist jetzt gestartet, auf Firefox auf, Terminal auf, ich darf auch wieder tippen,
sehr schön, und jetzt mal schauen ob ich jetzt in Web-EPG gehen darf, da ist der EPG, so
sieht der EPG im Cody aus und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich find das eigentlich auch ganz ok,
kann man die Bilder nicht, Bilder fürs Programm aus Google ziehen, ja aber wozu, ich mein,
ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass ich taxi nach Loch Ness ein gescheites Bild auf Google
finde und wenn, dann weiß ich ja nicht ob das was das erste Google-Suche-Ergebnis ist
auch wirklich ein Bild ist für die Fernsehsendung, ne ich glaub nicht gescheit, ja also so sieht
der EPG in Cody aus und so ungefähr hätte ich mir das ganze dann auch im Web-Interface
vorgestellt, aber erstmal kleine Schritte, weil erstmal ausprobieren, dass ich sowas
hin bekomme, ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, so ich mach mal jetzt zur Inspiration, kopier
ich mir den Kram auch mal rein, so also hier ist das Projekt, ich clone mir das jetzt erstmal,
in der Hoffnung ich krieg das zusammen wie man cloned mit SSH ohne das ich eingeloggt
bin, über TV-DB-AP ziehen, nee, schaust du denn echt so viel aus dem, ich schau gar
nix, ich schau gar nix, der einzige Grund warum ich das jetzt umgebaut hab ist weil
meine Mutter viel guckt und die hatte richtig Probleme mit dem Kram was bisher ist und ging
mir immer auf den Keks mit, oh Max da Fernseh geht nicht und keine Ahnung irgendwie spielt
die Aufnahme nicht ab und sonst was, deswegen hab ich jetzt die Box gekauft, diese Linux
TV Receiver Box und hab TV Headern drauf geklatscht und das funktioniert ja auch ganz gut, ja
und letztens ging es darum kann man nicht einfach auf dem Tablet Sachen programmieren,
ja, die saß irgendwie im Bad oder so mit der Katze und wollte nicht hoch und hat gesagt
kann man nicht EPG programmieren oder kann man nicht, nee die sagt ja nicht EPG die sagt
ja kann man nicht Fernsehzeitungen programmieren, auf dem Tablet hab ich gesagt doch, da gibt's
die offizielle App hab ich rausgefunden und du könntest über das Webinterface machen
aber das sieht kacke aus und hab ich, wie das heißt, das ist irgendeine Mario Playlist,
keine Ahnung, 20 Minuten, Spirit Tracks natürlich ist das Spirit Tracks Kamep gleich bekannt
vor, das ist die Musik, die Zugfahr, die Zugfahrmusik von Spirit Tracks, nee oder, aber auf jeden
Fall Spirit Tracks, weiß ich ob das die Zugfahrmusik ist, so ok klonen wir, achso gehst du fort,
so klonen wir das ganze mal schnell, Repos, wobei, Rider Projects Git, klonen, so wie
klaut man denn jetzt gescheit, so ist wie hier das SSH Git Add, gell, ich glaub so, aha
siehste, das funst schonmal, weil ich hab mein SSH Key hier hinterlegt und hab auch
den gleichen SSH Key lokal, so also EPG Champ, da drin gibt's jetzt zwei Ordner, einmal fürs
Backend und einmal fürs Frontend, ihr wisst ja, Mono Repo ist der Shit aktuell, das machen
wir natürlich auch, früher hat man das auch so gemacht und hat es nicht Mono Repo genannt,
es ist bisschen übertrieben das Mono Repo zu nennen, ja, Max macht jedem Stream 4 Tage
Vorbereitung, ja klar, das darfst du es jetzt auch nicht verraten alles, was ihr nicht wisst
ist, ich hab für den Patrick was programmiert letztens und das hat tatsächlich glaub ich
eine Woche oder so insgesamt gedauert, weil der wollte ganz komisches Zeug, irgendwas
Azure Active Directory krempeln und ich sag euch, diese Microsoft API ist so abfucked
Pains Champ, bis man das gecheckt hat, ja zum Glück, ich mein ohne Mist ne, wenns funktioniert
ist es tatsächlich eigentlich relativ klar was passiert, wenn man sich das anguckt, aber
bis man rausbekommen hat, wie man den Krempel verwendet, das hat gedauert, Graph API kann
auch sein ja, zwar was mit Azure Active Directory und ich krieg's gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen,
aber das Projekt ist private, das gibt's nicht, also gucken wir uns das mal an, also das Web
Interface, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal was das Backend aktuell schon macht, Rider starten,
achso wir können grad mal kurz gucken, ob es für Rider irgendwelche Updates gibt, dann
waren wir das schnell, gibt's Updates, es gibt Updates, das updatet sich natürlich
erstmal selbst, gut, die Microsoft Doku sind echt so ein Spezialfall, also die sind, also
ich muss sagen, ich find's ja gut, dass Microsoft relativ viel hat, das Problem ist nur, die
haben teilweise zu einem Thema 5 Dokumente mit fast ähnlicher Überschrift, du weißt
gar nicht welches das jetzt eigentlich ist, was du verwenden musst, mittlerweile ist es
so, dass es standardmäßig auf Deutsch übersetzt, wenn du auf Deutschland aus Deutschland drauf
gehst, was richtig bescheuert ist, muss immer oben auf Englisch drücken und die Dinger
sind teilweise unsinnig, äh was hab ich nie auf, keine Ahnung, äh die Teile sind unnötig
komplex ja, ihr kommt drauf an, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder es ist was überschaubares
und es ist so klein und es interessiert mich, dass ich sag ich probier das mal so oder aber
du musst mich bezahlen und ich bin nicht wirklich teuer muss man sagen, je nachdem wie interessant
das ganze ist, so, installieren wir den Kram erstmal, für privat schon ja, verbüßt es
nicht, das stimmt, das ist richtig, ja, wobei man ja sagen muss, ich hab mit dem Patrick
auch keinen Vertrag gemacht, ich hab gesagt ich guck mal und am Ende hat er mir einfach
das überwiesen, was passt, ja und alles in die Steuererklärung rein, ihr wisst ich hab
nicht umsonst eine Firma angemeldet, auf die kann ich mehr oder weniger alles laufen lassen,
ich mein ich hab zwar als ähm, wie heißt das, wir haben einen Zweck oder so, hab ich
kreative, ich überleg grad, kreative Webgestaltung oder irgendwas in der Richtung, da fällt im
zweifelsfall auch Webanwendung programmierend runter, wisst ihr, so, jetzt hat er geupdatet,
gut, zack, tools, keep previous, nein, download cache, leftover, nein, nein, lass, lass,
ok, Rider aufmachen, bist du Ausbildung Studio, ja hab ich, hab ich, hab ich gemacht, aber
schon lange her, ich hab 2007 mal Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt, Steuerfahne mit,
der kann mithören, da kann er nämlich einfach zu meinem Steuerberater gehen und sich, ich
wurde übrigens letztens geprüft vom Finanzamt, ja, kann er einfach zu meinem Steuerberater
gehen und sich das angucken, da ist alles in Ordnung, ok, ich geb zu, das wird wahrscheinlich
jeder sagen, das wird wahrscheinlich auch ApoRed sagen, wenn er den Insimodus aktiviert,
dass alles in Ordnung ist, aber ich hab nicht umsonst direkt von Anfang an einen Steuerberater,
der das macht und ich bin da auch wirklich pingelig, was das angeht, also insofern,
bei mir ist es wahrscheinlich verschwendete Zeit, sag wahrscheinlich, weil, gut, mein
Steuerberater vielleicht auch nicht perfekt ist, keine Ahnung, aber im zweifelsfall ist
dann mein Steuerberater schuld und ich, ich, nee, ich, es kostet zwar ein bisschen was,
aber ich hab keinen Bock, ich hasse so Steuersachen, ich will nur, dass das ordentlich ist, ich
mein, ich hab's euch, ich hab's euch ja schon mal erzählt, mein Vater war mal fast im Knast
wegen Steuerhinterziehung, ist ewig her und als ich das, ich hab das ja damals mitbekommen
und das war für mich, als ich klein war, was ganz Schlimmes, wenn der Vater, ja, da Probleme
hat und irgendwie ist es bei mir hängen geblieben, dass ich mich nicht mit dem Finanzamt anlegen
sollte und vor allem, man sollte bei dieser einen Sache nicht denken, das ist das, wo
sich wahrscheinlich auch ApoRed was von abschneiden kann, man sollte bei dieser Sache nicht denken,
man outsmartet die irgendwie, weil das macht man nicht, das macht man vielleicht kurzfristig,
mein Vater auch gedacht, das macht man vielleicht kurzfristig, aber langfristig, wenn du nicht
gerade Amazon bist, nicht, dann hast du gelitten, guckt euch Boris Becker an, er hat bestimmt
auch gedacht, Alter, ich bin richtig big brain, wobei, wie der auf die Idee kommt, big brain
zu sein, keine Ahnung, ja, es sei denn, du bist so wichtig und so groß, dann ist das
auch wieder egal, wie ich sage, wenn du Amazon, aber selbst bei Amazon und sonstigen Sachen,
da sind sie mittlerweile ganz schön hinterher, die haben aber halt Massive-Five-Header, die
immer irgendwelche Tricks haben, so, also, machen wir das mal auf, wo sind wir stehengeblieben,
also, EPG-Champ, da ist er, Backend, alles klar, den EPG-Champ, wir trusten dem EPG-Champ,
so, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal kurz, was ich schon gemacht habe,
dass man so einen groben Überblick hat, dann machen wir die Web-Anwendung, ich denke, was
ich an Backend habe reicht aktuell halbwegs aus, also, was wir haben ist ein.NET Core,
nee,.NET Core sagt man nicht, ein.NET 6 Projekt mit Minimal-APIs, so, der Einstieg
sieht so aus, ist relativ überschaubar, ich zeige euch das mal, das hier ist Boiler-Blade-Gedöns
für ASP.NET Core, das geht nicht anders, also, hier, ich habe eine Config-Datei, die
liegt da, die sieht so aus, kann man angeben, wie viele Tage EPG man abfragen will, bei
der Gelegenheit muss ich gleich mal mein Passwort und so eintragen, dann muss man sein TV-Hat
und Passwort und Username eingeben, man muss die Adresse eingeben, wo der TV-Hat und erreichbar
ist, das ist bei mir hier, deswegen habe ich übrigens vorher auch das Git-Ignore gemacht,
da würde ich mein Passwort da nicht ins... Habe ich Mist gebaut im Git-Ignore? Hä? Warum,
die habe ich plötzlich geschrieben, guck dir mal, config.json, warum interessiert das
ich dir überhaupt dafür? Du musst es mit Git-RM entfernen? Sicher? Man kann doch Dateien
comitten und danach nie wieder updaten mit dem Ignore-File. Doch, kannst du, auf jeden
Fall, aber bin ich jetzt verwirrt irgendwie? Kannste es echt nicht? Ich bin mir so ein,
dass ich das schon gemacht habe. Git-Ignore legt nicht den Projekt, ne, legt bei mir in
dem jeweiligen Ordner für die einzelnen Unterprojekte. Ging das echt nicht? Doch, das ging! Egal,
mit sowas halten wir uns jetzt nicht auf, dann liege ich halt mein Passwort, das juckt
mich nicht, da kommt eh keiner von außen dran. Also, ich habe eine config.json-file, ob man
YAML nehmen kann, bin ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher. Mal gucken, ob das YAML kann
standardmäßig. Add, was kann das denn alles? Command-Option-Environment, any-files, ich
meine, das ist Microsoft, High-Secure-Passwort, any-files, json-files, xml-files, memory, key,
ne, YAML kann das nicht, da bräuchte, also standardmäßig kann ASP.NET Core keine YAML
config. Soll mir, soll mir recht sein, ist jetzt auch egal. Also, ich habe eine config,
da stehen die ganzen Credentials für meinen TV-Headernd drin. Die configs werden geschrieben
in eine, in ein Objekt hier, App-Settings und dann habe ich einen Wrapper gebaut, zeige
euch gleich, für die TV-Headernd API. Den habe ich hier registriert, wird initialisiert
mit der Adresse vom TV-Headernd, mit dem TV-Headernd User, mit dem TV-Headernd Passwort. Dann
habe ich einen EPG-Updater-Service, muss ich euch gleich mal zeigen, gucken wir uns dann
an. Der Pult, alle 30 Sekunden, einmal neuen EPG vom Server, also von dem TV-Headernd.
So, Fileserver müssen wir machen, dass wir Webseiten ausliefern können. Ja, und dann
habe ich aktuell genau einen Endpunkt, slash, EPG und er holt sich den aktuellen EPG und
liefert den zurück. Also, dann starte ich das Ganze und hier habe ich noch ein paar
sinnlosen Klassen. Also insgesamt 60 Zeilen Backend in der Program CS, also ist sehr übersichtlich.
So, ich zeige euch das mal,.net-run, jetzt haben wir curl, localhost 4500 slash epg,
dann muss ich einen Doppelpunkt machen und jetzt kriege ich ganz viel EPG zurück. So,
jq, dann sieht es jetzt besser aus, colorless, so, das bekomme ich jetzt gerade zurück von
diesem AP Endpunkt, hier, den kompletten EPG. Geht auch relativ schnell, wie ihr seht, und
das obwohl es durchaus ordentlich, ordentliche Menge ist, also es sind 10 bis 14 Tage EPG,
also ist schon ein bisschen was. So, und wie das Ganze funktioniert ist folgendes, hat
wer eine Empfehlung für einen DVB-C-Stick? Ja, habe ich, also mit der VU-Plus-Box bin
ich zwiegespalten, also ich habe mir so eine VU-Plus-Box gekauft, mit OpenART-TV und TV
hier dann drauf finde ich das Ding auch wirklich nice. Einfach ist es aber nicht, wenn du einfach
nur einen TV-Stick haben willst, die ganze, ich kann dir den empfehlen, den ich die ganze
Zeit am Raspberry Pi dran hat, von dem weiß ich es, WinTV Dual USB, hatte ich die ganze
Zeit an meinem Raspberry Pi dran, den hier. Dual Tuner Stick, den hatte ich die ganze
Zeit an meinem Raspberry Pi dran, musst mal gucken, ob du den billiger kriegst. Fand
dein letztes Video übrigens mega, warst du dir sicher? Das ist schön, ich versuche es
auch immer so zu erklären, dass man es halbwegs versteht. Manchmal schwanke ich so ein bisschen
zwischen, ich erkläre quasi für die Noobs so, das ist eure Browser-Leiste und danach
sage ich dann irgendwelche anderen Dinge, die advanceder sind, aber ich versuche so,
dass jeder zumindest die Chance hat, das zu verstehen. So, also, wie funktioniert das
mit dem EPG aktuell? Ich habe hier einen EPG-Updater-Service, das ist ein Feature von
ASP.NET Core, ich glaube es heißt immer noch ASP.NET Core, weil ASP.NET ist ja vorbelegt
vom alten.NET Framework, ASP.NET Core, die haben das Core behalten, während sie es bei
.NET rausgeschmissen haben. Microsoft-Benahmung, machen wir uns jetzt weiter keine großartigen
Gedanken drüber, okay, weil sonst kommen wir da nicht mehr raus. So, es gibt ein Feature
in ASP.NET Core, das nennt sich Add Hosted Service, da kann man eine Klasse angeben,
die man automatisch im Hintergrund laufen lassen will und das ist diese Klasse hier
bei mir. Ich habe hier einen Background-Service, den ich EPG-Updater-Service genannt habe und
was der macht ist folgendes, der bekommt als Config die Settings, die App-Settings, also
das was in der JSON-Datei steht, der bekommt ein TV-Hat-and-AP-Objekt, womit ich dann
mein Backend querien kann und das einzige was der macht ist, der startet eine Endlosschleife,
warum ich hier eine extra Schleife, einen extra Tag starte, weiß ich gar nicht so genau,
das müsste ehrlich gesagt auch komplett ohne funktionieren, an die Essung, ja anscheinend
funktioniert das auch komplett ohne. Schauen wir mal ob das auch wirklich so ist. Das was
der macht ist, das wird standardmäßig vom Framework aufgerufen, Execute Essung, das
passiert, wenn man hier sagt Add Hosted Service und das macht im Prinzip eine Endlosschleife,
wo er immer wieder den neuesten EPG abruft, in Current-EPG speichert, Current-EPG ist
das was ich hier bei Slash-EPG zurückliefer, guck da und dann wartet er 30 Sekunden und
macht das ganze nochmal. So und die eigentliche Sache zum EPG abrufen funktioniert folgendermaßen,
ich hab einen TV-Hat-and-AP-Wrapper gebaut, den gucken wir uns auch gleich an, übrigens
es gibt auf GitHub, es wäre nicht möglich gewesen ohne Dave P., weil Dave P. hat ein
Wiki angelegt mit inoffizieller AP-Dokumentation für TV-Hat-and. Wäre natürlich noch cooler
hätte er da eine Auto-Generated Swagger-AP gehabt oder sowas, man muss ja ein bisschen
mit der Zeit gehen, aber so ist auch ok, da weiß man wenigstens wie der ganze Krämpel
funktioniert. Und bei der Gelegenheit ist mir wieder eingefallen, dass ich vor einer
ganzen Weile einen richtig coolen Service mal entdeckt hab, den kann ich euch zeigen,
kennt ihr das? Ihr bekommt so eine AP-Dokumentation, das steht drinne, ah hier guck mal, die Antwort
sieht so aus und jetzt setzt ihr euch hin und macht irgendwelche Klassen die dieses
Jason nachempfinden. Ich hab folgendes gefunden, vor einer Weile schon, QuickTypeIO, guck mal,
da kann man nämlich einfach sagen, ich will dieses Jason umwandeln in C-Sharp-Code und
zwar nur JustTypes. Und schon macht ihr deinen Jason zu einer.NET-Klasse und die kann man
einfach reincopy-paste und gut ist. Das geht mit Postman, das geht mit Wishl Studio Code,
das geht auch mit Wishl Studio, aber in Rider geht das witzigerweise nicht. Aber das ist
tatsächlich ganz praktisch dieses Teil. Ja, ist nice. So und was jetzt passiert ist folgendes,
der ruft sich vom TV Head & Backend alle Fernsehkanäle ab, die es gibt, dann macht er eine Schleife
über alle Fernsehkanäle und dann ruft er sich den EPG für diesen Fernsehkanal ab und
legt einen neuen Channel mit EPG-Daten an. Da steht drinne Name, da steht sowas wie das
erste HD drinne, irgendeine Aldi für den Channel, die Nummer intern vom Channel, eine
Uhrl, wo man sich das Channel-Logo abrufen kann und dann legt er EPG-Einträge an für
den Kanal. Also sprich, man bekommt zurück eine Liste mit Channels, wo jeder Channel
dann alle EPG-Einträge drinne hat. Magic, ja. So, so funktioniert das. Und deswegen,
das wollte ich nicht alles im Stream machen, sonst kommen wir nicht zu der eigentlichen
Geschichte. So und dann gibt es ein TV Head & Api Objekt, was dann unter der Haube die
eigentlichen Requests macht, so wie der das hier beschrieben hat. Also, das sieht dann
so aus, du kriegst erstmal die Adresse, den Usernamen, das Passwort, dann hängt er nochmal
slash api an, weil es immer slash api sein muss hier davor, ja, basic auth macht er,
weil Username, Passwort und dann gibt es dann zum Beispiel sowas wie getepg for channel,
das ist das, was wir gerade aufgerufen haben und dann sagt er einfach, hol mir mal von
dieser Adresse, das sieht man hier auch bei dem Typ, das habe ich alles bei dem von der
Webseite, ja, also der macht ein Get-Request gegen die URL vom TV Head & slash epg slash
crit, also das da, übergebt die Channel-ID, wofür er den epg haben will, sagt so viel
wie geht an epg-datenladen und dann sagt er, ja, mach einen Get-Request und pass die Response
als json. Ich habe hier intern noch so ein paar Objekte, die ich brauche, dass die api
Kommunikation funktioniert, aber das ist ziemlich wurscht. So, das müssen wir uns nicht weiter
angucken. So, und jetzt kriege ich, wenn ich slash epg mache, meinen epg zurück und das
ganze, ihr seht es ja, es fängt mit einem Array an, dann ist ein Sender-Objekt drinne
mit Sender-Name, Sender-ID, Sender-Nummer, Uhrl, wo ich das Sender-Logo bekomme und dann
epg-Entries und in epg-Entries ist dann alles drin, sortiert nach Uhrzeit, guckt hier, 12.19,
13.19, sortiert nach Startzeit mit Startzeit, Endzeit, Event-ID, Description, wo es aus
irgendwelchen Gründen erstaunlich wenig, ne, ist so, Description steht dann in dieser
ganze Krempel drin, den der Sender reinschreibt. Luki, ich habe ein Projekt gefunden von einem
auf GitHub, der es in pap gemacht hat, ist das das von dir, der sowas ähnliches probiert
hat? Ja, da gibt es den Titel und das hier unten brauchen wir später noch, es gibt
noch die Info, ist dieses Event schon zum Aufnehmen programmiert, ja oder nein? So,
das wars im Prinzip, das müsste uns erstmal als Info reichen, damit wir jetzt das Webfrontend
machen können, das heißt wir verschieben das mal und machen hier dann gleich Wishlist Studio
Code auf, ne nicht Backend, Web, da wollen wir hin, kann sein, hab es öffentlich, ich
hab was gefunden, aber das hatte 30 Sterne oder so, ich weiß nicht ob das das ist, das
ist aber schon, was ich gefunden hab ist einmal in Python, einmal in pap, das sah halt auch
aus als ist es ein paar Jahre alt, das hat mir optisch dann nicht so gefallen, ich hab
auch nicht weiter reingeguckt, aber es kann sein, dass es in pap war. So, also wir haben
hier ein Projekt, das machen wir auf in Wishlist Studio Code, zack, äh, ich hab grad mein
Terminal verschoben, dabei wollte ich Wishlist Studio verschieben, so wunderbar, nein wir
machen an keiner, wir nehmen an keiner Umfrage teil, alter, Wishlist Studio kann schon nerven
manchmal, installier, komm gib ihm, Platformer IO, als bräuchte ich jetzt irgendwelche Arduino
Geschichten, so, ähm, dann starten wir das Projekt, na, äh, open, irgendwas mit open,
oder, minus, minus open, so war das glaub ich, genau, oh, Swell, Kit, not found, NPM, install,
vergessen, reload, so, source, roots, index, html, also ihr seht, ich hab noch nichts gemacht
in dem Projekt, kein Frontend und nix, open, so, also es ist, ja, ihr habt YouTube Dislikes
aktiviert, also, das ist das Standard Projekt Template, was man so bekommt, ohne, ohne irgendwelche,
Spirenzien, also gar nix gemacht, großartig, ähm, so, also wir brauchen jetzt, brauchen
als erstes mal eine Runde Tailwind, CSS, weil, ich hab mich da mittlerweile so dran
gewöhnt, benutze das gern, für CSS-Krempel, so, NPM install, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
gucken, wie man überhaupt ordentlichen EPG rendert, ich hab so eine grobe Idee, wie
man's machen könnte, aber ich bin mir unschlüssig, ob das funktioniert, und nachdem ich weiß,
wir haben hier ein paar richtige CSS-Fiveheader, ist das nochmal gut, dass ich das im Stream
mache, weil CSS bin ich wirklich nicht so der Massive Expert, was das angeht, so, also,
wir löschen erstmal diesen ganzen Krempel, und schreiben den alt bewährten Testtext
drauf, also, Hallo Welt ist aus, Hallo CACW ist angesagt, so, läuft, läuft, gut, jetzt
können wir unseren EPG abfragen, und gucken, ob wir den gerenert bekommen, im Browser,
so, machen wir das jetzt, Patch, EPG, ne, Async, müssen wir das machen, also, war, hier,
mal anders, EPG, jetzt müssen wir den Kram runterladen vom Server, also, EPG in Browser,
übrigens, wir machen hier gar keine Mühe, dass irgendwie, Fuzzy, ne, wie nennt man das,
wie heißt das, wenn du Sachen nachlädst, während du, während es in View kommt, ich
meine nicht Endless Scroll, so, lazy, lazy, nicht fuzzy, lazy, lazy, wir machen hier nix
mit lazy, loading, oder sonst was, wir laden jetzt einfach mal, ja, wir laden jetzt einfach
mal, 46.000 Zeilen, EPG, das ist gar nicht zu viel, also, wir laden jetzt ungefähr,
2 MB, 2 MB, Jason, das war in Browser, das wird der Browser schon verkraften, also, war,
keine Ahnung, Response, Await, Fetch, Leute, ich hab, ich hab da mal eine Frage an die
ganzen pfeilfertigen Web, Webentwickler, ähm, verwendet ihr Fetch oder verwendet ihr was
anderes, ach stimmt, let, let, ja, ihr habt recht, let, ich hab zu viel, ich hab zu viel
.net gemacht, nebenbei gerade, klar ist es wahr, Neo Fetch, ja, ich, ich verwende nicht
Neo Fetch, ich verwende, ähm, ach wie heißt das, fuck, ich hab's vergessen, verwende
weder Neo Fetch, noch was anderes, Axios, ja, ist das, ist das so viel einfacher mit
Axios, als, als mit Fetch, dass sich das lohnt, was ist der Unterschied zwischen let und war,
also, ich so als Java 3 Head, das liegt, das hat was mit dem Scope zu tun, also ich glaube,
der Unterschied zwischen let Variable und keqw Variable ist, war ist global und let ist local
zu dem Funktionsblock, oder so, in der Richtung, man kann aber auch so machen, das hab ich
auch nicht verstanden, warum das auch erlaubt ist, also du kannst ja in, du kannst ja in
Javascript, ah ne, das geht doch nicht, ok, du kannst ja, du kannst ja in Javascript let
machen, war, ich, ich bilde mir ein, man konnte, konnte man nicht mal gar, konnte man nicht
sogar ursprünglich mal so machen in Javascript, ohne, ohne irgendwas, na gut, also Fetch, so,
wo wollen wir hin, wir wollen nach HTTP, doppelpunkt doppel slash, localhost, host, 4500 slash
epg, so, und dann gucken wir uns mal die response an, ähm, übrigens, ich muss euch noch was
zeigen, was ich, was ich mir vorhin ausgedacht hab für dotnet, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob
das eine gute Idee ist, was ich mir da ausgedacht hab in dotnet, aber, ich hab, ich hab eine
helper, helper Klasse gebaut, und zwar, guck mal, Sekunde, ich muss hier grad mal auskommentieren,
was ich zeigen kann, also, warum geht das auf rot, wenn ich program cs aus, ah, weil ich
die Klassen auskommentiere, ich noob, ok, da muss ichs anders machen, warte mal hier,
return, ähm, ich hab, ich hab was gebastelt, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das eine gute
Idee war, also, ähm, machen wir anders, machen wir hier, machen wir hier, äh, da, also hier,
so, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich Sachen von der api abrufe, an der Stelle, guck mal hier,
Rest ist wurscht, nur, nur das hier, gucken wir uns mal nur das hier an, also, hier sag
ich, tv, tv, ja dann api get channels, so, was ich gebaut hab, ist folgendes, guck mal,
tvh, api, get channels, und jetzt kommt es ja total oft vor, dass man sowas machen will,
guck mal, sowas will man ja total oft machen, so, als Debug-Ausgabe zwischendurch mal,
ähm, auf der, auf der konsole was, was ausgeben, wenn ich das so mache, funktioniert das natürlich
nicht, da krieg ich als antwort, das ist ein task, der noch läuft, und selbst wenn ich
sowas mache, krieg ich, krieg ich jetzt ja nicht gescheit, geprintet, wie das Array
aussieht, was ich als antwort bekomme, Christi, danke für den sub, und ich hab mir jetzt folgendes
gebastelt, guck mal, und wenn man das macht, und wenn man das, wenn man das aufruft, dann
macht der ein konsol-log für das was da drin steht, guck mal, ich zeige euch das, wenn
ich das jetzt starte, gibt es ein langes konsol-log von diesem Ding, guck da, Debug-Ausgabe von
dem Objekt, und einfach nur weil man Punkt-Dump hinten dran schreibt, so, hast du schon mal
programmiert mit Vim, ja, ich war sogar mal so verrückt, und hab versucht, und hab versucht,
ähm, Vim mit Plugins aufzubohren, ich hatte mal irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 800 Zeilen
Vim-RC oder sowas, aber mittlerweile bin ich, bin ich weg davon, ich hab relativ minimalistische
Vim-RC nur noch, und editiere alles in der Kommando-Zeile über Vim, und den Rest mach
ich mit irgendwelchen grafischen Editors, ein bisschen Vim-Übung ist natürlich immer
gut, gerade wenn du Sachen über SSH editierst, so, und das finde ich eigentlich eine coole
Sache, das funktioniert, falls euch nicht auch gefallen ist, das Ding hier ist S-Sync,
das funktioniert für S-Sync, und es funktioniert auch für synchrone Sachen mit Dump, guckt,
ja, wobei, glaubt's mir, es funktioniert, so, und wie ich das gemacht hab, ist folgendes,
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das eine gute Idee ist, ich hab zufälligerweise auf
Stack Overflow was gefunden, guckt mal, ich hab das hier gefunden auf Stack Overflow,
was es macht, ich bin mir da selber nicht so ganz sicher, aber es funktioniert, sieht
sehr agin aus, ja, also von der Idee her, wie hatte ich denn das vorher, die Größe,
so, so, so hatte ich's, glaub ich, oder, was, egal, also was der macht, ist folgendes,
ich will ja, dass diese Konsolenausgabe funktioniert auf S-Sync-Objekte oder auf Synchrone, also
auf Task, also ich gucke erst mal, ist das, ach so, das ist der Extension Method auf Object,
dass es überall verfügbar ist, dann guck ich, ist das Objekt ein Task, wenn es ein
Task ist, dann warte ich, bis der fertig ist, synchron, und dann caste ich diesen Task in
ein Dynamic, und diesen Dynamic-Task caste ich dann wieder in ein Object, nee, nee, Moment,
ich caste diesen Task in ein Dynamic, und dann rufe ich Punkt Result auf, weil er bei
Dynamic nicht checkt, ob es die Methode wirklich gibt, außer erst zur Laufzeit, und das Ergebnis
davon caste ich dann zurück in ein Objekt, und dann jage ich das durch einen JSON-Serializer,
raus, der es mir für die Konsole formatiert, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das eine gute Idee
ist, weil ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, also, das hab ich von Stake Overflowed, also
nicht alles, sondern nur das da, weil ich es danach explizit gesucht hab, ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass es Deadlocks gibt, wenn man nicht aufpasst, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es so ist, es sieht nur ein bisschen danach aus, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man
damit seine Programme im ungünstigsten Fall freezen kann, oder halt in irgendeine Endlosschleife
hängen lassen kann, ich kann euch nicht genau begründen, warum, aber irgendwie instinktiv
sieht es ein bisschen danach aus, aber es funktioniert, also deswegen kann ich jetzt, deswegen kann
ich jetzt sagen, deswegen kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, hier Dump, und es kriegt es auf der
Konsole als Debug, ist aber auch wurscht, wollte ich euch mal zeigen, weil, ich fand
es eigentlich eine coole Idee, ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob es eine gute Idee ist,
also weiter im Text, wir wollen unseren EPG abrufen, Fetch, Lock, Await, Result, JSON,
und funktioniert nicht, achso, ich muss das vielleicht noch aufrufen, Fetch, EPG, alles
klar, doppelt, ne, einfach, was ist ein EPG, das ist ein elektronischer Programm, das
ist quasi eine Fernsehzeitung, eine elektronische Fernsehzeitung, also guck mal, das hier ist
ein EPG, das hier ist ein EPG, da weißt du, dass es jetzt gerade im ersten gibt, eine
Hochzeit platzt selten allein, Alter, diese Titel, Pains Jam, wofür, dass man Sachen
programmieren kann, über den Browser oder übers Tablet, mit einem schönen modernen Webinterface,
so, also weiter im Text, ne, ist kein XML, das ist kein XML, so, also jetzt bekommen
wir, jetzt bekommen wir unseren, unseren EPG, das ist auch schon mal schön, also können
wir sagen, EPG gleich, so, und was steht hier jetzt drinnen, den Krempel, den ich über
die API ausliefer, guckt mal, genau das, was wir uns gerade mit JQ angeguckt haben, ich
krieg die Url für den Sender, ich krieg den Namen vom Sender, ich krieg die Sender-Nummer,
ich krieg ne Unix-Sender-ID und ich krieg, krieg EPG Entries für in dem Fall RTL2, so,
und jetzt überlegen wir uns mal, wie man da draußen scheitern EPG rendern können, denkt
dran, die werden mit unserer, es wird alles, es werden auch die Renten der, der, der Leute
bei ARD und so mit, wird alles mit unseren Beiträgen bezahlt, also, wir machen jetzt
mal ne Schleife drüber, also, each, vielleicht soll ich das nicht EPG nennen, sondern, also
Leute, ich bin froh, wenn wir heute so weit kommen, dass wir einen EPG haben, der scrollbar
ist und wo alles drin steht, dass wir dann das nächste Mal das mit der Aufnahme machen
können, oder so, mal gucken, mal gucken, vielleicht ist das auch viel einfacher als
gedacht, also, each channel, ist zwar nicht so schön sprechend, aber ok, guck mal mal,
channel, tatsächlich, äh, äh, Sekunde, wie, wie, wie hab ich's genannt, name, channel
name, aha, guck mal, passt schon mal, sieht doch schon mal gut aus, channel name, RTL2,
MDR Thüringen HD, Leute, es ist zum ersten Mal, also, ich wusste bis heute nicht, dass
es diesen Sender überhaupt gibt, MDR Thüringen HD, warum hat Thüringen, MDR, warum gibt's
er einen eigenen Sender für, Sender für, gut, hessische Dings gibt's ja auch bei uns, warum
nicht, Chat, ich moge kurz reingucken, danke Slim Beats für den Sub und danke an alle anderen
Subs, falls ich welche übersehen hab, wie sagen die Amis immer dann in ihren Streams,
much appreciated, sag ich aber nicht, weil dich das dumm anhört, sort der Sender, ja,
das sollten wir tatsächlich noch machen, du hast recht, wir sollten die Sender, siehst
du mal, gut, dass der Chat dabei ist, wir sollten die Sender sortieren, und das zwar
Server-Seite schon, nach der Sender-Nummer, weil dir egal ist, ey, ich hab's letztes Mal
so rumgeschleimt, das muss ich nicht jedes Mal machen, oder, aber danke für deinen Sub,
du hast schon den, du hast schon den Diamant-Keks, also M Sentry sagt, hey Chat, ich versuche
gerade eine Web-App für ein Salon-Buchungssystem zu bauen, Exen, warum, just for fun, für
den Vater, für Bekannten oder Auftragsmäßig mit Kohle, oder irgendein Studium-Projekt
oder in welchem Rahmen machst du das, also sprich, wie gut muss das am Ende funktionieren,
du Friseur-Kumpel, okay, also gibt keine fette Kohle, so, also, dazu muss ja eine Art Kalender
entstehen, der die Öffnungszeitenverfügbarkeit der Mitarbeiter, und das ist gar nicht so,
ich sag dir mal hier, also, ohne Mist, das ist, das hört sich erstmal easy an, ist es
aber nicht, die Source, die über ein Datum jedes Mal die obige Dinge prüft, oder würde
es mir im Sinn machen, ein Kalender, SQLite-Datenbank im Backend, du brauchst kein fettes Postgres
oder sonst was, mach eine SQLite-Datenbank im Backend dafür, es sei denn, du möchtest
es nur auf einem Rechner und nur in einem Browser verwenden, dann könntest du das
alles auch klein-seitig machen, aber willst du wahrscheinlich nicht, denke ich mal, also
ich würde eine SQLite-Datenbank machen, da musst du dir halt irgendwelche gescheiten
Mappings überlegen, ja, also, keine Ahnung, du hast eine Klasse für Termin, du hast eine
Klasse für Kunde, du hast eine Klasse für Mitarbeiter, und dann kannst du dir halt
eine Tabelle machen mit Termin, ist dann quasi so die Many-to-Many-Tabelle für, nee, das
stimmt überhaupt nicht, nicht Many-to-Many, es ist ein Termin, ein Termin hat einen Kunde
und hat einen Mitarbeiter, aber ein Mitarbeiter kann mehrere Termine haben, und ein Kunde
kann theoretisch auch mehrere Termine haben, aber nicht bei dem gleichen Mitarbeiter, also
brauchst du auf jeden Fall drei Sachen, du brauchst was für Mitarbeiter, du brauchst
was für Kunde und du brauchst was für den Termin, und in der Termintabelle joins du
das Ganze dann zusammen, das musst du nicht selbst machen, das kannst du über deinen
Datenbank-Mapper deiner Wahl machen, der in einem Web-Framework drin ist, ja, mit Entity-Framework
ist das total simpel, mit Entity-Framework sagst du einfach hier SQLite-Datenbank und
registrierst deine drei Klassen und geht es, ja, und dann musst du eine API machen, sowas
wie, keine Ahnung, Add-Termin, Delete-Termin, Put-Termin oder keine Ahnung, und dann musst
du gucken, dass das sich nicht überschneidet, also es kann ja mehrere Termine gleichzeitig
geben, aber es kann nicht der gleiche Mitarbeiter mehrere Termine haben, ja, also ich würde
im Backend eine SQLite-Datenbank, theoretisch kann doch der Kunde mehrere Termine beim gleichen
Friseur haben, ja, aber nicht gleichzeitig, das habe ich auch gesagt, ein Kunde kann
mehrere Termine haben, ein Mitarbeiter kann auch mehrere Termine haben, aber ein Termin
hat jeweils nur einen Kunde und jeweils nur einen Mitarbeiter, ja, und das ist gar nicht
so einfach, ja, sowas zu machen, also ich würde eine SQLite-Datenbank nehmen und dann
minimalistische Web-Arpita-40 das alles checkt, aber es ist tatsächlich das gut zu machen,
verdienbar zu machen und auch so, dass es fehlerfrei funktioniert, ist gar nicht so einfach,
also das ist jetzt kein totales Einsteiger-Projekt, würde ich sagen, ja doch, das ist schon Reihenfolgen
gesichert, weil ich das Jason ja generiere und ich generiere es immer in der richtigen
Reihenfolge, also, was der Chat gerade gesagt hat, ist richtig, der Chat hat Recht und zwar
sollte man diese Sender sortieren und zwar nach, äh, sort, ach fuck, wie ist es, order,
heißt es nicht, order, achso, weil, weil, erst mal, ähm, order by, order by channel number,
so wollen wir das haben, ja, weil, jetzt ist der Channel mit 1 auch oben, ich glaube, das
ist ganz sinnvoll, probieren wir das mal aus, ob das jetzt funktioniert, also das erste
müsste jetzt zuerst kommen, ja, ok, funktioniert, so, ok, jetzt haben wir die Sender in der richtigen
Reihenfolge sortiert, es ist gut, dass der Chat dabei ist, du würdest trotzdem den Sort
kleinzeitig machen, denn man kann man dort A bis Z, ja, kann man ja immer noch machen,
aber ich finde, dass es standardmäßig vorsortiert ist nach Sender-Nummer eigentlich ganz sinnvoll,
das kann man alles machen, ich will jetzt erstmal gucken, wie man ein EPG malen, bevor man solche,
wir machen mal eine Sache, Chat, ähm, EPG to do, wir schreiben uns das mal auf, dass
wir es nicht vergessen, ähm, kleinzeit sort, A bis Z, Z bis A, Nummer, wir machen erstmal
Stassi-Schneidermann-Diagramm, so, vertikal, horizontal, ausrichten, ähm, skip to primetime,
feste Uhrzeiten, ich schreibe mir das alles auf, nicht, wie gesagt, ich kann es jetzt
erstmal nicht alles einbauen, nur zu gucken, gibt es eine Funktion zum Channel-Nummer,
nein, nein, nein, wir machen nichts, das einzige, was wir hier machen können, ist, wo man wirklich,
was ändert am Backend, ist eine Aufnahme beauftragen, also das ist kein Web-Frontend, was das TV-Hat-And-Web-Frontend
ablösen soll, sondern das ist nur eine schöne Ansicht und Aufnahmefunktion für den EPG,
also man kann keine Channel-Nummer ändern, man kann keine Profile anlegen, man kann keine
Passwörter ändern oder sonst was, das einzige, was wir machen können, ist EPG abrufen und
neue Aufnahmen anlegen und Aufnahmen löschen, fertig, aus dem EPG, weil ansonsten ruft das
aus und ich will ja auch nicht das TV-Hat-And-Web-Interface nachbauen oder so, sondern ich will einen schönen
EPG haben, der im Desktop funktioniert und auf dem Tablet funktioniert, am besten als
PWA noch.
So, Alter, ich kann das mal, mein Ding, mein Mauszeiger gecrappt behalten jetzt.
Also, so, jetzt haben wir das sortiert, jetzt sollte das erste oben stehen, guckt, da steht
das erste oben.
Das ist Linux, das ist noch Manjaro, Manjaro mit I3-WM als Window-Manager, so, jetzt haben
wir unsere Channels, so, jetzt müsst ihr mal mitdenken, Chat, doch, das muss fertig werden,
weil mich sonst meine Mutter nervt und sagt, ich kann nicht programmieren und das bugt
rum und was auch immer und dann muss ich wieder rübergehen und sagen, ja, ich leiste Support
für den Fernseher und ich hasse Fernseher, ihr wisst, dass ich Fernseher hasse, also
Fernsehprogramm, oldschool, analoge Fernsehtechnik, ich hasse es komplett, der Gramm muss funktionieren
und dann so gut, dass ich das einmal hinschmeiße und das läuft dann für 300 Jahre, in Wirklichkeit
schaut der Rosamunde Pilcher, ja, ich guck das alles in Wirklichkeit, ich guck Rosamunde
Pilcher, ich guck Wege zum Glück und alles, ja, alles, komplett, Lilly Schönhauer, was
gibt es denn da sonst noch, Traumschiff mit dem Florian Silbereisen, Forsthaus, Falkenau,
der Bergdoktor, ja, die Shopping Queen, oh Leute, ich muss mir wirklich mal die Shopping
Queen angucken, das war aber woanders, war nicht daheim, alter, das war cringe, ich hab
den Sinn der Sendung nicht verstanden, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab ohne Scheiß,
ich hab den Sinn dieser Sendung nicht verstanden, also, also, warum diese Sendung gemacht wird,
ich, also, wisst ihr, wisst ihr was ich meine, also, warum ist jemand auf die Idee gekommen
und hat die Shopping Queen gedreht, also, ich, ich verstehs nicht, also im Prinzip ging
es ja darum, soweit ich mich da dran erinnern kann, im Prinzip ging es ja darum, es gibt
irgendwie ein paar Kandidaten und die sollen dann einkaufen und wer das ganze irgendwie
am günstigsten oder so einkauft oder am besten am Ende bewertet wird, ich weiß gar nicht
mehr genau, gewinnt, so, und ich muss mir das mal angucken, oh, die Moderatoren waren ultra
nervig auch, ich muss mir das mal angucken und ich muss das so tun, als gefällts mir,
weil, weiß gar nicht ob ich das jetzt erzählen sollte, weil ich gut Wetter machen wollte
bei derjenigen mit der ich das geguckt hab und da konnt ich nicht sagen, alter, was guckst
du für einen Kack im Nachhinein betrachtet, doch hätt ich das sagen sollen, weil dann
kommste wahrscheinlich als Sigma Chat rüber, wahrscheinlich hätt ich sagen sollen, alter
sowas guck ich nicht, ich geh jetzt heim, das wär wahrscheinlich dann, wie sagt man
heutzutage, der Alpha-Move gewesen, aber ich dachte mir, es ist eine gute Idee dazu bleiben,
weil danach könnte man ja noch was anderes gucken, was vielleicht nicht die Shopping
Queen ist, ja, keine Ahnung, es war ganz, ganz extremer Pains-Champ die Shopping Queen
zu gucken, so, da reden wir jetzt aber nicht weiter drüber, wir programmieren weiter,
also weil sonst wär ich nie fertig, Leute, Five Head Javascript und CSS Leute, wie könnt
ich jetzt denn ordentlichen EPG machen, also so Inspiration sowas in der Richtung, sowas
hier in der Richtung, ja, also ich muss das schon, also horizontal müssen die Dinge und
vertikal müssen die, müssen die Sender, also, so, wir machen jetzt erstmal das Sender-Logo,
weil das ist noch relativ einfach, Sender-Name, also das Logo, Image, Image, okay, wir brauchen
ein Image, Image ist, Mist, ich hab gar keinen Endpunkt für das Image, kann ich das direkt
vom Backend abrufen, das mach ich jetzt nochmal testweise, ob das funktioniert, das ist glaube
ich ne blöde Idee, was ich jetzt mache, warte mal, Channel, ich hab doch sowas hier, Channel,
Icon oder sowas, Icon-Uhrl, oder, hier, Image Cache 1820, kann ich das direkt so abrufen,
das mach ich nicht, Leute, ich sag, ich will nur gucken, ob es prinzipiell klappt, Slash,
oh, unauthorized, okay, das klappt nicht, ja, da brauchen wir, da brauchen wir was Neues,
da brauchen wir was Neues im Backend, dass das funktioniert, wir brauchen ein, okay,
ich hab ne Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen können, wisst ihr was wir machen können,
ich muss ja irgendwie das Channel-Logo abrufen, dass ich das hier anzeigen kann, also wisst
ihr was wir machen können, ich hab ne Idee, also, entweder machen wir eine neue Methode,
ein neues Rest-Backend, also sowas wie Image oder sowas, Image, weiß ich, wie ich das
nennen soll, Image-Proxy-Image und dann mit all die hinten dran, sowas könnten wir machen,
oder, was wir auch machen können, um uns ein bisschen davor zu drücken, wir könnten
auch in diesem Channel noch ein weiteres Feld machen, wo dann nicht Icon-Uhrl drin steht,
sondern String-Icon-Base64 und ich lade das im Hintergrund runter und hänge an jeden Channel
als Base64-encoded-PNG dran, das ist aber nicht so schön, oder, ich glaub, ich glaub, das
lassen wir, ich glaub, wir machen direkt Image-Uhrl, ha, Chat, was sagt ihr, wir machen Image-Uhrl,
ja, komm, wir machen Image-Uhrl, also, dann brauchen wir sowas hier, Image, guck mal Leute,
dann brauch ich das hier gar nicht, Base69 soll ich nehmen, das ist auch nicht schlecht,
gibt's auch Base420 schon, meine, genug Zeichen gibt's ja, sollte ja möglich sein, so, also,
jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen, also, Icon-Uhrl brauchen wir dann nicht mehr, weil,
die Reihen, die ID vom Channel sollte eigentlich, Moment, geht das überhaupt anhand der ID,
Moment, nach welchem, nach welchem Muster, nach welchem Muster ist das überhaupt aufgebaut,
das, die Icon-Uhrl, Icon-Uhrl, ist das, ist das der, ist das der, die Nummer, oder was,
ne, 18, das ist was komplett random, random-mäßiges, ok, dann lassen wir das nochmal drinnen, also
Image, wie, wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit, also, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall das API-Objekt,
dass ich hier was abrufen kann, ok, also, wie kriege ich denn jetzt das Image, Image-ID,
so, ID ist dann das hier aus der Uhrl, ok, also, dann sagen wir API, ne, was brauche
ich jetzt, ich muss das, ich muss das Bild abrufen, also, muss ich nicht, brauche ich,
brauche das API-Objekt gar nicht, ich brauche eigentlich gar nichts an der Stelle, ich brauche
die, doch, das brauche das API-Objekt, wir brauchen eine neue Methode in der API, um
das Bild abzurufen, ansonsten ist doof, also, gibt es nicht Full-EPG, sondern gibt es jetzt,
keine Ahnung, Get, Get Channel, Get Channel Icon gibt es jetzt, so, das ist gut, Get, Get
Channel Icon, irgendwie so, ja, so, und zurück, zurück gibt es Bytes, Bytes, so, und jetzt
testen wir erstmal, ob es funktioniert, bevor wir da irgendwelche Parameter und Gedöns
hinmachen, nehmen wir das einfach nur mal Image, nix, oh, API, Get Channel Icon, wir machen
jetzt ein Hard-Coded-Image und gucken, ob es funktioniert, ich habe eine Video zugemacht,
mehrere Videos, was ich mache auf der Arbeit, also, Get Channel Icon, Base-Uhrl, wie, wie
ist eigentlich die richtige Url, um das abzuzufragen, okay, Image-Cache, probieren wir das mal aus,
also, Curl, HTTP, Doppelpunkt, Doppelsecht, 192, 168, 211, 981, und jetzt Image-Cache,
unauthorized, okay, Massive Passwort, oder API davor, nope, ohne API davor, also, so,
so bekommen wir, so bekommen wir das Bild, das wollte ich mir dann nochmal überlegen,
wie man das gescheit machen, da kann ich jetzt noch nicht mal das verwenden, boah, das ist
ja eklig, Alter, warum ist das nicht unterhalb von API, dann kann ich hier nicht API-Standard
mäßig setzen, E-Git, Monka-S, kann ich, kann ich sowas machen, wie, Remove, Remove Segment,
oder so, Remove the last Segment, nee, das funktioniert nicht, äh, Suck, Alter, aber
okay, zum testen machen wir das jetzt mal so, mir fällt da grad nichts anderes ein, äh,
1, 8, 1, so, dort, und das ganze dann, Basic, Auth, ich Hardcode das jetzt alles, ich will
einfach nur gucken, ob da jetzt ein Bild zurückkommt, wenn ich das richtig mache, brauchen wir nicht,
äh, Get-Bytes, gibt es da sowas wie, Get-Bytes-Essing, und dann returnen wir das einfach, so, von
der Idee her sollte ich jetzt ein Bild zurückbekommen, Get-Channel-Icon, zeig mal her, Return Get-Channel-Icon,
ja, das ist ja nicht live, so, starten wir das mal neu und schauen, ob da irgendein
Bild zurückkommt, bei dem, was ich jetzt gebastelt hab, Hardcoded-Konst, ja, der neueste Trend
ist ja eh einfach, Hardcoded-Software-Engineering, also sprich, du nimmst dir einfach einen Code-Generator,
der dir jeden erdenklichen Input pre-generated, das heißt, du hast ein Programm ohne Input,
was wiederum heißt, dein Programm ist immer fehlerfrei, jeglicher Input ist Hardcoded,
mit allen nur erdenklichen Input und Outputs, das Programm ist dann zwar halt das komplette
Universum an Speicherplatz voll, aber es kann nie Fehler, und auch keine Tests mehr,
richtig, so, und jetzt wollen wir das da abrum, Localhost, Localhost 4500, zack, äh, Image
hab ich's genannt, ne, ok, das fun- das sollte funktionieren, Network, Image, ruft der Image
es ab, Image, warum ist das Base64, was zum, ich will Bites haben, nicht Base64, alter,
was soll das, was, warum, achso, ich kack nur, wait vielleicht, ne, moment, ich bin grad,
ne, wait, aha, aha, ok, ok, testen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, was ich mir da überlegt
hab, Image, warum Base64 encoded ja das denn, na gut, wahrscheinlich kannst du's anderweitig
nicht übertragen, oder, wie kriegst du sonst Bites zurück, wobei doch, ich kann, Moment,
Moment, das muss gehen, wie, wie, wie, wie geb ich ein Image zurück, Content-Type oder
sowas, Hab, Content-Type, Return, ok, irgendwie so, geht das so, ne, äh, boah, ich hab keine
Ahnung, wie man das mit Minimal-APIs macht, ok, das ist Base, das ist Base64, alles klar,
ist einfach, kann man Return File machen, das ist eine gute, Return File, ne, was, ach,
System Iow, nein, nein, das ist File, das ist falsch, nicht System Iow, äh, File Result
ist es dann wahrscheinlich aber das ist ja kein mbc das geht wahrscheinlich net
aber was will das von mir warum kann ich das nicht machen
ach nu nu vielleicht string content
ok das funktioniert so nicht wie wie man ein feil von der mini ok google fragen minimal
api ist die scharp return feil return image turn image
how to return image vom web api das weiß ich mit feil result ja aber das bringt mir bei der
minimal api nix return bytes kann man kann man sowas machen return string content
ich habe keine ahnung ok dann dann dann return wieder jetzt base 64 ok soll mir
recht sein wir return base 64 feil content result return feil content result excellent
feil fetter new feil contents get channel icon so und jetzt content typ image png
oh was hat er für schmerzen was will er von mir was what the fuck
was willst du von mir
was ich habe keine ahnung was das ding von mir will mach mal results feil
also sowas hier oder wie das ist ok das ist habe ich noch nie gemacht das ist
richtiger feil feiter kram feil contents ok und jetzt content type image png ok das
ist jetzt besser oder was ok wenn microsoft es sagt es ist jetzt besser
ob es dann machen wir das natürlich auch so so gibt es jetzt binary
warum gibt es html was frage ich denn da ab und warum gibt es warum gibt es html
get channel icon ach so leute ich bin ja auch doof image cache und jetzt ich frage
ob mich das richtige ablull das hat wahrscheinlich vorher schon funktioniert ok mal gucken ok das
sieht besser aus leute da kommen binary krams zurück gucken wir mal raus ob das funktioniert
keck w.png chrome keck w.png hey guck mal das ist sender logo so das heißt im endeffekt
auch wir sollten das ich probiere das noch mal anders was jetzt passiert wenn ich einfach
sage return api punkt get channel icon ob das jetzt funktioniert aber wahrscheinlich
muss ich das so machen habe ich sich erwartet erwacht also ok wahrscheinlich muss ich so
machen wie es vorher war ja ok der encoded das standardmäßig also dann dann machen
wir es so ok return file alles klar so sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön so und ich meine
ich will ja nicht ich will ja nicht immer das gleiche haben sondern ich möchte das
haben für jeden sender also sprich get channel icon das heißt ich muss hier noch irgendwie
einen sender übergeben von dem ich das bekomme und deswegen würde ich sagen machen wir das
mit einer id also sprich der id vom channel oder direkt den channel
direkt den channel das ist aber das ist aber echt
ist aber echt blöd ok ich weiß wie wir es machen also wir übergeben dem ding eine
id int id das kriegen wir hier rein in dem mit dem template dann sagen wir get channel
für diese id genau und dann sage ich image cache id
int id das muss man bisschen schöner machen weil das hier unten funktioniert ja so auf
dauer gar nicht so und jetzt kriegen wir das pro id so jetzt mal kurz mal kurz checken
ob das auch punzt ob da auch irgendwas irgendwas reinkommt image slash blub blub ja funktioniert
und rein ok so und jetzt müssen wir nur noch dafür sorgen dass der krempel ach so wir können
übrigens bei der gelegenheit mal testen ob es funktioniert wir übergeben einfach die
nummer die wir eben die ganze zeit benutzt haben 5 5 4 6 5 5 4 6 bam funktioniert ok
was ist denn war irgendwie image id oder so kann es einfach das als api pass nehmen ja
wie jetzt was wo stehe ich ach du meinst einfach hier dass ich das einfach weiterreiche
oder was dass wir das im prinzip dass das ist das ist das irgendwie so man keine image
und dann image cache slash id ja das ist tatsächlich eine gute idee das ist gut das
ist nice der chat denkt hier immer mit so dann machen wir das nämlich so das ist gut
ja also einiges ist doppelt aber es hält sich in grenzen finde ich die deswegen hat
sich ja noch js auch so durchgesetzt weil man sich einredet man könnte dann sachen
re re re usen was teilweise gar nicht so einfach ist weil guck mal ich habe beispielsweise
das die channel klasse die ich an klein schicke ist eine komplett andere channel klasse als
die die ich in meinem backend für für die für die api zum zum tv recorder verwende
aber da kann man bestimmt einiges sich sparen also das ist auch so gut so ich denke das
müsste so passen wie ich das jetzt mache also ganz im ernst dann ist das andere nun doch
schöner ok also das funktioniert dann gehen wir jetzt in den tv hat ein client gucken
da mal auch ob es passt ja das passt nicht wirklich aber für das erste soll soll es
das soll das reichen gut und jetzt sollte ich theoretisch für jeden channel einfach
ein icon bekommen guck mal ob das funktioniert channel icon es gibt schon mal keine fehler
das ist schon mal gut schon mal mal network ach shit alter was ist denn jetzt wieder für
ein problem doch das wird angefasst sonst gibt es nicht mehr wo ist denn jetzt wo ist
denn jetzt wo ist denn jetzt das problem icon wohl heißt das nicht icon wohl channel icon
image cache wieso das müsste eigentlich so funktionieren es müsste doch exakt so funktionieren
der schickt der kommt als antwort weil text plane weil 404 404 image cache habe ich nicht
neu gestartet oder so kann das sein image cache nee müsste doch funktionieren ich glaube
ich habe nicht neu gestartet exquisite guck mal da haben wir unsere sender logos das erste
sieht man nicht das erste ist transparent wahrscheinlich weil es weiß auf weiß ist
oder so wartet mal ich glaube das erste hat ein logo man sieht es plus nicht weil weiß
auf weiß und so invisible ok das funktioniert channel logo alles gut machen wir mal was
für class bg red nee bg grey ja da ist es guck mal funs ok leute channel logos sind
da was mir nicht gefällt ist das hier eigentlich will ich das nicht hardcoden hier drinnen
das blöde ist ich habe hier api angehängt was halt ich brauche für alles diese api aber
für image cache natürlich nicht also entweder hänge ich jetzt überall von hand api dran
kann man den kram einfach options wie options braucht da keine ich muss das weg machen
also sprich dann können wir nämlich an der stelle remove last path nee last path ist
ach in dem fall ist es tatsächlich api du hast recht ja doch das müsste funktionieren
also baseball remove remove last path segment ja da brauche ich die basic aus auch nicht
mehr so und jetzt append pass segment äh wie setze ich das denn jetzt an der stelle
nee so wird das nicht funktionieren ich meine theoretisch theoretisch müsste das funktionieren
also theoretisch müsste das so gehen aber das kann man bestimmt schöner machen kann
query parameter ist es ja auch nicht hat es irgendwelche optionen fully encode nee append
pass segments das machen pass segments brauchen wir das da und all die ja das ist gut das
ist gut das brauchen wir ok neu starten jetzt kannst du auch nichts mehr injecten großartig
funktioniert nice ok schön also unsere sender logo sind schon mal also image cache 500 ist
ok wenn es das nicht gibt was soll ich machen ja also sprich für zwei für zwei sender haben
wir kein bild kann ich nichts kann ich nichts machen ist dann halt so sollte ich da lieber
vier null vier vielleicht antworten wobei ich rappe das ja im prinzip nur wir gucken
jetzt erstmal dass wir das ui halbwegs hinkriegen so also wir haben jetzt unsere channel logos
das ist doch schon mal nice also von der nummer die inspiration angucken also wir machen links
die die die channel hin links die channel wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit mit flex
irgendeine flexbox geschichte oder so dass man da jetzt sagt flex
ich will es doch im endeffekt so haben also quasi na untereinander ist doch ok die dinger
sind ja schon startmäßig untereinander also quasi sowas hier und dann wie sowas nee was
mache ich denn da wie krieg ich das jetzt gescheit angeordnet default image gute idee
ja ja gute idee die fall image machen wir die fall image wisst ihr wisst ihr was die
fall image wird dass wir das die fall image oder keck wait oder keck wait
sekunde sekunde art kurz copy image image to bite array gibt es auch bestimmt online
irgendwas github chef nein wie heißt das ding cyber chef die haben auch die haben auch bestimmt
sowas die haben auch bestimmt was bei byte array oder so bei take bites remove bites
haben die nicht sowas ich weiß nicht nach was ich sagen muss da was ich suchen muss image
to byte eresse ich meine ich könnte das selbst machen aber will ich nicht online ich will
dass mir da einfach das rausspuckt ja das kann ich selbst ich dachte es gibt was was
wenn ein fertiges byte array ausspuckt wo dann das keck keck w drinne ist also wenn
einer gute idee hat drop bites take a slice of spam auf bites image filter image image
da war jetzt kein keck image ich meine ich könnte einfach das kam rund den kam runter
laden machen wir es so ich wir laden das runter auch im image so gehen hier in das verzeichnis
rein epg champ back end we get default punkt png wobei das könnten wir eigentlich auch
kleinseitig machen oder das könnten wir eigentlich auch kleinseitig machen wenn der wenn es wenn
der request ach komm wir machen schon wieder an so viel klein schitt drum so also die fall
png so wenn das hier nicht funktioniert wenn das hier nicht funktioniert also sprich
ich habe hier gar kein error handling hier drinnen ist ja ist ja gar nichts das versucht
einfach ok wisst ihr was bam keck wait return return file read bites default default punkt
png easy so machen wir das jetzt und nun kriege ich wenn es kein sender logo gibt kriege
ich keck keck w als antwort pass mal auf bam ja funktioniert wo ist er da ist er die
voll sender logo alles klar wunderbar top top sender logo finde ich gut ok also wie
machen wir denn wie ordnen wir das denn jetzt alles an also wir machen das bild auf jeden
fall schon ein bisschen kleiner keine ahnung 12 12 oder so oder 24 24 gibt es glaube ich
nicht hier noch 24 24 dafür brauche nur die weite nicht die höhe ja ok wunderbar wobei
eigentlich brauchen wir das gar nicht weil es macht einfach so breit wie immer glas
breite 24 jawoll wunderbar höhe 24 so ist das ok ok das sieht ja schon mal es sieht
ein bisschen so aus wie ein epg zumindest desender logos also ok jetzt kriegen wir erzählen
wie es geht das zum würde bei jedem sender als display block machen und die programme
als span excellent ich habe von so was wenig ahnung was css kram angeht das mache ich
jetzt einfach also du meinst das hier block und dann einfach so dahinter ne das macht
aber eine neue zeile oder wie würde man wie würde man das richtig machen ich habe da
so keine ahnung von also ich würde ich würde es wahrscheinlich ich würde es wahrscheinlich
anders machen also wir wollen ja im prinzip 2 2 sind es sind ja eigentlich zwei spalten
ne 2 doch zwei spalten prinzipiell es ist die erste spalte desender logo und die zweite
spalte ist dann der epg also das hier das hier ist quasi spalte 1 muss ich drüber
schreiben css gritt bringt uns css kritt was ich glaube css kritt wird nicht so viel bringen
weil ich am ende die mit irgendeinem inline style die breite machen muss die elemente
die nebeneinander liegen sollen display inline ok inline inline ok alles klar also also wenn
ich das so mache habe ich jetzt zwei logos auf der a ok ok ok verstehe ok wir machen
den hintergrund ein bisschen anders hintergrund irgendwie 100 oder so reicht so wobei es
eigentlich so besser aus vielleicht sogar 900 800 800 wachs nicht so viel zeug so also
jetzt haben wir den kram hier und so könnte ich da jetzt auch mein programm dahinter malen
von der idee her ok ok feife da teile feife teile wie machen wir das jetzt wir malen also
die weite will ich auf jeden fall schau mal nicht die höhe will ich genauso haben damals
bg irgendwas was ich auf jeden fall besser erkenne gray 200 oder so dass ich den bloß
ne das funktioniert nicht chat das funktioniert nicht cheat 95 du hast ahnung das weiß ich
du hast schon öfters irgendwelche sachen erzählt in der richtung also zeig mal ich
würde ein krit mit zwei spalten machen und in der zweiten spalte das welt ist ein javascript
frontend frontend framework also ich würde ein krit mit zwei spalten machen und in der
zweiten spalte dann die einzelnen programme als blöcke nebeneinander liegen machen und
diese die zweiten spalte an overflow scroll machen so nie auf was kreuz overflow scroll
können wir nicht machen das geht nicht overflow scroll funktioniert auf mobile nicht gut
das muss alles in diesen main part von der seite rein
sag mal aber chat so wie ihr mir das jetzt erzählt habt sollte das doch eigentlich nebeneinander
liegen oder machts aber nicht warum
boah ich hab ich scheitere jetzt schon an so einfachen css dingerl alter also ich hab
keine ahnung also wie können wir das jetzt zumindest ordentlich anordnen justify center
item center nee monkaS so vielleicht aha aha ah jetzt ist das in der mitte das ist besser
ist das nicht unter das image elemen nee ah alter css please wie machen wir das jetzt
was wird dieses project das fertig ist ein web epg sowas in der richtung wie das hier
wo man dann sachen aufnehmen kann und löschen kann wenn man tv dann verwendet aber ich hab
mit frontend sachen so meine probleme ok lass mal kurz in mich gehen wie würde ich denn
wie würde ich das machen mit einem krit also krit
mit ins diff unter das image nee oder doch nicht unter das image das unter das image
mach nee das funktioniert so nicht leute
das problem ist die elemente ich kann die nicht in einem flex anzeigen lassen weil
ich muss mit mit dem inline style die breite gleich machen das backend gibt's schon ja
ja also moment das backend gibt es in zwei varianten es gibt einmal mein backend was
die sachen serve für mein frontend und es gibt natürlich das backend vom tv hat etwas
auch eine eigene api hat um überhaupt an den epg dranzukommen und sowas also wie kriegen
wir das dann jetzt hin man das kann halt so schwierig sein krit krit krit columns two
ok hellwind krit weiß ich wie man das verwendet ich weiß aber auch nicht wie man die normalen
sachen verwendet krit hier massif krit krit calls alles klar gap das ist wie viel abstand
dazwischen ist ok und jetzt noch ein neues diff da rein diff keck weh ahja das ist schon
besser jetzt haben wir zwei verschiedene sachen ok klas bg krei ahja aber aber das ist jetzt
ja gleich breit das will ich ja nicht ah frontend kram pains jam wie mache ich das
denn jetzt ey krit krit ist glaube ich keine gute idee krit scale das ja ich will das
nicht scale das muss hart hardcoded sein was die breite kannst du auch mit h0 angeben ok
keiner ich mach das jetzt einfach mal wieder chat das sagt also ok flex flex call dann
ist alles schon mal untereinander das ist das ist ja prinzipiell nicht teckert so wenn
ich hier was reinschreibe dann kommt natürlich auch untereinander das heißt im endeffekt
ich muss jetzt moment warum ich muss roll ich muss standardmäßig lassen oder so so
komm mal jetzt ist doch jetzt doch ok klas bg 200 da werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
ein viertel stunden für braun bis ich das gecheckt habe wie man das gescheit macht
so also ok ok overflow muss auf jeden fall auf hidden und jetzt brauche ich ein inline
style für die breite sagen wir 100 pixel soweit wenn das so klappt wie ich mir das
gedacht habe hier die breite errechne ich dann wie lang die sekunde dauert oder chat
oder wir machen das so wie der mwm sentry schreibt ich probiere mal was mir besser gefällt
sagt mal hier diff für das sender logo ok diff für das sender logo ist ja so ok wie
ich es habe und dann sparen aber das hatte ich doch das hat nicht funktioniert das das
ist nicht jeder neben das ist hier untereinander das das klappt so nicht oder muss ich das
auch zum sparen machen was jetzt ist ja schon roll flex ist standard alter ich ich check
es nicht ok das das funktioniert nicht dann bleibe ich mal bei dem weil das funktioniert
ja prinzipiell gut flex breite ok das funktioniert auch weil ich muss ja im endeffekt den kram
dann skalieren können je nach wie lang die sendung ist wir probieren es jetzt einfach
mal so bevor ich da jetzt noch ewig rum mache also hier haben wir das sender logo und hier
haben wir das kw logo wenn sonst nichts gibt also wenn sender logo fehlt so wir machen
hier noch eine sache drum immer noch padding ja viel besser viel besser gleich dem element
kannst du dann die klasse w0 flex crow geben ich will es nicht flex crowen das muss die
breite ich falls das macht was was ich denke ich muss die breite auf jeden fall so angeben
es soll nicht so dynamisch sein auf gar keinen fall weil sonst stimmt die breite von den
einzelnen einträgen nicht es muss ja gesünd sein also die sender müssen ja zur gleichen
zeit untereinander sein ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ob das funktioniert so also jetzt
probiert jetzt versuchen wir mal was anzuzeigen lassen da drin also ich bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob das klappt moment das funktioniert jetzt schon nette leute das funktioniert jetzt schon
etwas ich hier mache sobald ich den nächsten kasten habe ist er wieder unten drunter ne
ist er nicht ach nee weil flex weil flex ok ist nicht ok ok alles klar alles klar weiter
im text so each channel punkt vor wie habe ich das genannt kannst du für die dynamische
breite nicht die bildschirm relativ breite angeben naja schon aber innen drin muss ich
das setzen mit fester breite weil die sender müssen ja gesünd sein untereinander ich
glaube das funktioniert sonst nicht ich könnte höchstens beim resize das neu berechnen keiner
leute ich probiere jetzt erstmal so hinzubekommen dass es zumindest so halbwegs nach dem epg
aussieht und dann optimieren wir da noch ein bisschen dran rum also epg event wie habe
ich den grabe hier genannt epg entries heißt das epg entries s epg entry ist nicht wie
ich es nennen soll da ist auf jeden fall da ist auf jeden fall pro sender ist da was
ja muss die höhe noch angeben
jetzt mal ernsthaft was macht der da was bin ich da sehen überhaupt was was sehe was
genau sehe ich denn da
ok das an sich an sich ja der ks ich habe overflow hinten gemacht ja wenn ich das weglasse
dann steht da kein quid drin aber ich muss overflow hinten machen weil ansonsten kann
ich die breite nicht einstellen da muss einfach mehr rein ok breite mal breite 500 aber sollte
der kram nicht einfach immer muss ich muss ich so was eigentlich min min ok schon besser
schon besser hat irgendjemand eine glorreiche idee warum eine sender logos nicht mal da
sind aber display block kannst du im flex doch nicht machen oder block
also das mit der angabe zur breite und so funktioniert nicht nicht also die epg anzeige
ist gar nicht so schlecht ja die die tut schon mal so wir testen jetzt mal hier schreiben
jetzt rein was wie der titel der sendung ist also epg entret title ok wie wie wissen
ich will das auch nicht ich will das auch auf gar keinen fall text rappen hier drin
no rap rap text white space no rap will ich haben so das ok dann nähern wir uns der
sache schon mal da stehen jetzt sachen untereinander und jetzt muss ich die breite machen in line
block das funktioniert in flex ich muss mir das gleich überlegen jetzt schreiben wir
hier noch nicht den titel drunter jetzt mal noch hier start zeit startzeit alter hör auf
visual studio code mitzudenken startzeit ii moment ne ne ne ne new date kann man das überhaupt
so machen juni vierter ok anscheinend checkt er das to local time string perfekt so machen
wir das mal ein bisschen breiter warum kein br naja weil es nebeneinander sein soll nicht
unter ok das das das das das sieht ein wenig aus wie ein epg so jetzt machen wir da noch
ein ein border drum border border grey ja ja leute leute wir kommen wir ok das sieht schon
mal ein bisschen nach epg aus jetzt das nur die sache ist die nur mit flex funktioniert
das halt nur und die sendung sind noch nicht allein untereinander warum nicht na grit ist
das problem dass ich das automatisch ne tabelle könnte man tatsächlich machen ich glaube
tabelle ist gar nicht so blöd in dem fall einfach eine eine seite mit dem logo und die
zweite seite mit dem mit dem ich glaube eine tabelle ist gar nicht so schlecht das finde
ich ist eine gute idee tabelle tabelle ist ist glaube ich poc table benutzt man nicht
wegen mobile optimierung aber wenn es funktioniert so jetzt waren wir noch mal hier date stop
wir müssen jetzt ein wir müssen jetzt erst ein paar sachen hinkriegen erstens warum wird
das komische vielleicht muss ich ja auch min min width setzen ach dann geht das ja das
kannst du jetzt nicht sein oder also ich will hier was ist punktuell das welt ist ein javascript
framework ich meine von der idee sieht es schon ein bisschen aus wie ein epg jetzt
müssen wir nur mal gucken wie man die die die länge einstellt pro sendung ok weil so
stimmt hier hinten und vorne nicht das stimmt hier hinten und vorne ich guck mal hier ist
zwei uhr geht's los und da geht's moment kann man nicht so was machen wie die e dass
es in deutscher zeit steht nicht kokona time das doch ganz gut so das 13 14 also sprich
wir müssen jetzt erstmal die breite richtig einstellen pixel pro sekunde genau also wir
brauchen jetzt so was wie erst mal hier irgendwie halt seconds zu pixel ok und zwar für das
epg entry wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig habe sehr kon alter ich kann schreiben seconds
ok function wir wie wollte ich das nennen kalk seconds zu pixel ok epg entry das sieht
nicht nach sie scharpe aus nee sie scharpe ist das beckern ist die scharpe das freund
ist javascript 12 so also jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich ausrechnen wie groß wie wie wie
lang dauert die sendung ok die sendung dauert im prinzip war nicht wahr wir sind wir sind
javascript let duration seg gleich epg entry stop minus epg entry start wenn ich das richtig
sehe warum funktioniert das in javascript über ich hab noch nicht mal ein return wert
warum warum macht er überhaupt irgendwas gerade der darf nichts machen das ding hat
kein return wert da kommt nichts raus aber in javascript ist das alles kein problem
anscheinend barcode champion ok jetzt haben wir die duration in seconds lock duration
seconds none ah weil das keine zeit ist das ist ja gar keine zeit das ist einfach nur
ein timestamp den ich noch in eine zeit umwandeln muss kann man den javascript gescheit dates
voneinander abziehen überhaupt nee wir brauchen das wir brauchen das jetzt hier ja aber wie
macht man denn wie würde man das mit javascript subtract date what the fuck get date was so
was macht das da überhaupt ok es gibt zwei probleme die objekte sind keine times und
vielleicht sollte ich das hier beim fashion einmalig machen vielleicht soll ich das hier
beim fashion einmalig machen dass ich sag ok response oder hier jason dass ich das einmalig
in irgendein zeitobjekt umwandle oder sowas initial moment moment das das machen wir jetzt
machen wir jetzt mal kurz das das das mache ich noch mal das mache ich noch mal kurz weg
hier wir bleiben aber 500 pixel zum testen so wenn ich alles richtig gemacht habe dann
sollte das hier funktionieren jetzt kackt es ab ist ja klar weil es weil es kein connection
refused all seriously ich habe es geschafft das back end zu crashen ne nicht das back
end die die diesen swell prozess was zum wie habe ich das jetzt hingekriegt 0w also das
war schon mal keine gute idee was ist denn jetzt wurde letztes problem wieder alles rückgängig
gemacht ach so weil ich doppelt away mache das wird das das wird das problem sein wusste
gar nicht dass es crashen kann das war mit dem war mir so nicht bewusst so also wir müssen
jetzt erst mal gucken dass das alles ein zeitobjekt ist wenn wir da auch loslegen jetzt kreischt
es also es kreischt nicht aber es funktioniert nicht also sprich wir müssen jetzt gucken
wenn wir dieses jason am anfang des in epg abrufen dass wir dort alles das wird dort
die start stoppfelder zu einem time objekt umwursten also for each channel so channel
for each epg entries epg entry und jetzt ist das pains champ start gleich new date so was
stopp und jetzt oh alter jetzt werft man nicht rum was ist das hier ach so das ist ein array
das darf da nicht sein pains champ aber guck mal es funktioniert es hat funktioniert so
jetzt haben wir da time dinger draus gemacht das ist schon mal gut jetzt müssen wir nicht
jetzt müssen wir nicht 3000 mal sachen eingeben sondern können das direkt miteinander rechnen
ok also ok das war mal nicht pixel 500 sondern je nach halk seconds to pixel epg entry was
wird wenn es fertig ist ein epg wo man sachen programmieren kann drüber also eine fernsehzeitung
im entfekt so bisschen so was hier wie das was du bei bei bei plexi ist nur für tv headern
und so dass man es auf mobile gescheit funktionieren kann benutzen kann dass man es dann in mobile
auch auf die startseite enden kann und so was ok duration kann man einfach zwei dates voneinander
abziehen und javascript macht damit
also ganz ehrlich das sieht nicht wirklich richtig aus ich mein sie das sind ganz schön
lange sendung seconds to minutes a busy feel aber das könnte tatsächlich sein eineinhalb
stunden aber zwei stunden sendung nee meint ihr das sind die sekunden vielleicht sind
das milli sekunden ja kann man was passiert denn eigentlich jetzt mal ernsthaft wenn man
zwei date objekte abzieht voneinander in javascript was passiert dann geht das überhaupt ja milli
sekunden hier nicht mit das in sekunden jetzt das kann durchaus sein also das nämlich duration
ms mit return die duration in sekunden was jetzt achso das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht
aus es ist aber auf jeden fall ein bisschen zu bisschen zu viel
teilen wir das mal durch 10.000 ja das sieht doch gar nicht schlecht aus jetzt haben wir
quasi 10 pixel pro sekunde oder sowas glaube ich na guck ist das jetzt das jetzt pro sekunde
und das hier sind dann 10 pixel also das das hier das hier macht milli sekunden das hier
macht milli sekunden zu sekunden und noch eine stelle weiter sind dann quasi 10 pick
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung 10 pixel pro sekunde so egal aber von der idee her scheint
das ganz gut zu funktionieren nee es ist nicht falsch was jetzt noch falsches ist die an
die start die startzeit ist unterschiedlich aber an sich ist das erstmal nicht verkehrt
also guck mal es geht beides zur gleichen zeit los guck mal 14 uhr 14 uhr 30 ist hier
14 uhr 45 ist da und jetzt gucken wir mal 20 uhr 45 20 uhr 45 müsste beim ersten und
beim dritten gleich angeordnet sein 20 uhr 15 meine ich haben die nichts um 20 uhr 15
aber 21 uhr 15 haben sie irene hus versus tagesthemen das ist gut das ist richtig angeordnet
also sprich solange die startzeit gleich ist passt es guck hier 10 uhr 10 gucken wir mal
gucken wir mal hier bisschen weiter da wir brauchen sachen die zum gleichen zeitpunkt
starten ja das das kommt schon hin aber können die mal bitte zur gleichen seite sendung anfangen
zwar guck mal hier tagesthemen hessenschau das passt das passt das ist das ist richtig
also die die berechnungslogik ist ist sinnig ja
es trifft er wenn die die plöcke ne border border ändert doch nix an ändert der border
was an der größe der elemente oder geht border nach innen 21 uhr 45 zum beispiel doch ist
doch richtig dass da unten kannst du nicht nehmen dass da unten die die zwei muss man
vergleichen das und das und das ist doch gut es ist doch genau untereinander hier guck
mal
ja ihr dürft nur die zwei vergleichen ihr dürft nur die zwei vergleichen nur die zwei
weil das sind die die gleichen startzeit haben der rest hat keine richtige startzeit
wie gesagt ihr dürft nur die vergleichen die gleiche startzeit haben der rest kann
nicht funktionieren weil es hier zum unterschiedlichen zeitpunkt anfängt also das liegt nicht am
border guck mal das liegt daran weil vielleicht liegt es auch am border ich muss das anordnen
dass das start dass das start immer zur gleichen urzeit ist also sprich ich muss jetzt quasi
gucken was ist die aktuelle urzeit und dann jeden sender nach links verschieben vom offset
der aktuellen urzeit her also von der idee her muss ich jetzt glaube ich so was machen
guck ob das funktioniert von der idee her muss ich jetzt glaube ich so was machen also
erste mal denke ich mal brauchen wir hier einen extra wir brauchen extra gift rum da
ich das verschieben kann ja ok also wir brauchen das dass ich verschieben kann so das heißt
wir sagen jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt jetzt probieren wir was margin warum habe ich hier kein auto
für vollstellung left minus 100 pixel minus minus 200 pixel ja das funktioniert von der
idee her wir müssen jetzt noch gucken dass die sender logos da bleiben wir müssen wir
müssen die sender logos irgendwie dahin bekommen die sender logos sollen da bleiben kann ich
da kann ich sagen sticky oder sowas sticky ne left null so ganz funktioniert es aber
trotzdem auch nicht was ich hier gebaut habe
weiß jemand warum es keine auto für vollständigung gab weil es hier wahrscheinlich durcheinander
kommt mit meinem krempel was ich hier mache normalerweise guck hier geht sie auch github
oder github was ist der beste move in der regel immer github github brauchst du mal
beidem geht es ja die eigentliche versionsverwaltung das hat auch wenig mit lokal oder remote zu
tun sowohl github als auch github oder gox oder bitbucket was sie das sind ja alles
irgendwelche frontends die versuchen deine repos irgendwie zu managen und visualisieren
geht es als eigentliche kommandozahlen repo verwaltungstool aber hier mal bg grey bg
grey hier rein bg grey
wie ist es vielleicht muss ich sticky sticky kommen sticky muss ich hier machen ach fack
alter warum geht man kann flex und sticky bestimmt nicht zusammen verwenden ok ich
bin ich bin unfähig atml also ich kriege ich kann es nicht
aha aha was warum hört es auf sticky zu sein nach der zeit was hä warum ist das so
bis mitte der seite sticky ich checke frontend sache nicht man das liegt bestimmt daran weil
ich keine weil ich keine breite angegeben habe oder sowas ich muss bestimmt warum habe
ich hier nochmal eine klasse drum herum die macht keinen sinn wozu ist das überhaupt
da ich blicke mein eigenes html nicht mehr leute macht die klasse sinn die ich ja außen
drum herum hat die hat irgendeinen sinn hat absolut keinen sinn gehabt das ist das ist
der container für den ganzen krempel ok wahrscheinlich muss ich nämlich hier sagen style breite
20.000 pixel witz die witz muss ich angeben so und jetzt kann ich bestimmt auch weiter
scrollen ah guck mal jetzt jetzt wird bis 20 hier sind 20k erreicht wahrscheinlich
warum warum ist das überhaupt ein ding warum warum ist das nicht dynamisch oder oder oder
ich muss sagen voll voll width vielleicht die position absolut bringt mir nichts das
kolle ich sehr raus und position fix bringt mir auch nicht weil hier oben und unten ich
brauche sticky witz ok max max content wie ich macht es jetzt einfach mal weil weil wenn
der chat das sagt dann ich glaube dass dem chat einfach mal massif es geht einfach weg
achso es geht weg weil die lpg vorbei ist ok das müssen wir doch irgendwie fixen das
ist nicht schön das ist wobei ich eigentlich eigentlich ist es ein ganz cooler effekt sogar
oder eigentlich ist der effekt sogar relativ cool es geht weg wenn der epg aufhört eigentlich
ist der effekt gar nicht so schlecht so jetzt muss wir erstmal gucken wie man den epg richtig
anordnen können so minus 200 ok das das das minus 300 jetzt funktioniert das hin und her
schieben nicht mehr leute ich kriege anfälle warum funktioniert jetzt das hin und her schieben
nicht mehr
jetzt kann ich jetzt kann ich nicht mehr schieben warum nicht eben ging es doch noch das heißt
es liegt das liegt da dran oder liegt ja muss ja da dran liegen oder da fehlt ein excellent
tie feather time ok ah ja ok und endmonarchs ja gut gut gut also so jetzt muss ich ausrechnen
wie fange ich an was nicht verschieben bei der with abziehen das ist eine gute idee ne
moment das ist ja ganz falsch ich will das doch gar nicht hier machen moment moment
ich will es nicht hier machen ich will den hier verschieben den den den ganz den den
außen der der außentrum herum ist aber moment ich will den ich brauche einen balken für
einen channel ich brauche ein ding pro channel so und das ist doch wobei es doch richtig
ich brauche einen balken pro einen balken pro channel das ist doch der hier den hier
muss ich schieben den hier muss ich doch schieben margin left minus 100 pixel ja das ist ok
ok ok passt passt so so ist das so ist das richtig so und jetzt jetzt jetzt schiebt das
jetzt schiebt das links aus leute ich habe die idee was wir machen massive massive idee
das muss ja mein to do to do schreibt es mir gerade ist mir gerade eingefallen wir machen
hier oben hier oben muss ja dann noch die urzeit hin beziehungsweise hier oben muss
der tag hin na also welch an welchem tag wir gerade sind weil aktuell war hast du ja keine
ahnung an welchem tag man ist und da machen wir oben so einen so einen farbverlauf dass
es nachts in den nachtstunden ist das hit ist der hintergrund blau in den tagstunden
ist der hintergrund gelb dann siehst du nämlich anhand von du hin scrolls ob du tags oder
nachts bist massive das war mal heller farbverlauf nach urzeit ja es wird gerade eingefallen
und wir machen das durchsichtig also wir könnten man könnte das sogar so machen guck mal man
könnte sagen opacity ok das sieht ein bisschen kacke aus das sieht das sieht eigentlich
gar nicht übel aus oder oder noch besser leute ich habe ich habe noch andere idee wir
machen wir machen blöhr das blöhr hat das logo blöhr background brauche ich oder wie
das geht bg blöhr oder blöhr blöhr blöhr ne wie macht man das wie macht man bg backdrop
blöhr will ich haben funktioniert nicht ok tailwind bg blöhr unterstützt das überhaupt
alle browser bg white was ok das ist ein cooler effekt leute das gefällt mir so prinzipiell
nur dass es scheiße aussieht wie ich es gerade mache aber aber vom effekt hier an sich finde
ich eigentlich eine coole coole sache ich bin mir aber bisschen unschlüssig wenn das
backdrop ist auch schatten nehmen man kann auch background blöhrn probieren mal bg black
weiß nicht wie man das macht braucht man da tailwind color rgba oder so die uhrzeiten
passen nicht ganz doch passen doch das ist nicht richtig angeordnet ja das weiß ich
schon kann man bg white durch 30 kann man einfach sagen bg links durch ah guck mal da
da kann man die opacity ein also tailwind ist 6 header wirklich massive 6 head ich finde
den effekt gar nicht so gar nicht so doof muss ich sagen guck mal man kann es gut erkennen
und es sieht es sieht ok dass es verschwindet muss ich das das nervt mich aber an sich ist
das doch gar nicht übel da kann man sogar durchgucken jetzt hier vielleicht mal lieber
noch mal 30 oder so wie hast du dein twitter schief gemacht ich habe das gar nicht gemacht
das hat er serious max gemacht das ist ein was ist das bootstrap und und ich weiß eben
mit was er das gemacht hat ich glaube bootstrap hat er für das css ok das sieht doch ganz
sieht doch ganz ok aus jetzt auf 50 gibt es das auf github das archiv ja das archiv gibts
irgendwo auf github da war ich aus dem kopf so mal nach agil agil progas oder so auf github
die haben das die haben das hochgeladen agile progas oder irgendwie so heißt den ihre auga
auf github ja so und da gibt es das archiv front und das archiv backend der lädt das
aus dem watt der nimmt das watt von twitch und lädt es dann irgendwo anders hoch keine
ahnung das hat das hat das baro und das serious max irgendwie zusammen gewurscht da weiß
ich nicht wie das funktioniert ok leute das finde ich das finde ich schon mal ganz ok
oder das kann man das kann man doch so kann man so lassen viel größeres problem ist wie
schaffe ich das jetzt dass es richtig zur richtigen zeit anfängt weil die urzeit ist ja nicht
richtig servus tv vielleicht vielleicht sollte man noch ein bisschen abstand dazwischen machen
weil so und ganz im ernst ich glaube wir brauchen hier ja kein rounded border rounded border
ist ziemlich ja das ist besser als rounded border ich meine es sieht nicht wirklich schön
aus aber das können wir noch schöner machen wir können auch ein bisschen padding machen
dass es nach innen besser aussieht ja schon besser schon besser titel nehmen wir mal font
bold text xl ja das sieht doch jetzt schon immer gar nicht so verkehrt aus
das stimmt aber was nicht leute das stimmt was nicht da ist eine sache die mir nicht
gefällt dass kein titel abgeschnitten ist das stimmt was nicht guck mal hier der hat
aber overflow hinten warum interessiert ihn das nicht das overflow hinten ist das stimmt
was nicht den titel sollte ich nicht ganz lesen können das stimmt nicht die titel müssen
abgeschnitten sein wegen min width sorry ah moment ich muss min width und width wahrscheinlich
setzen das müssen wir irgendwie anders machen das gefällt mir nicht ja so ist besser ok
weil ansonsten stimmt stimmt stimmt die die breite wieder nicht so ist ja jaja jetzt passt
es nämlich schon deutlich besser ja ok und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen wie wir das
ausrechnen dass es immer an der gleichen stelle anfängt dass das wird noch mal 5 hat
was passiert denn wenn ich will machen wenn ich wenn ich die wenn ich die jetzt einfach
auf null stelle was passiert dann dann geht es weiterhin ja ja manchmal will ich die
woz nicht drin haben so also passt doch schon mal ok wie kriegen wir das jetzt gebacken
kannst du im backhand nicht einfach einen filler entry hinzufügen doch aber das bringt
ja alles nix die die sender haben halt unterschiedlich viele einträge und die sender haben halt
sendungen die nicht unbedingt immer zeitgleich anfangen dass ich muss das auf jeden fall
verschieben also ich brauche jetzt ich muss ich muss jetzt irgendwie den offset ausrechnen
also sprich wie wie ich brauche ok ok lass mal überlegen ich brauche die aktuelle zeit
ja ich brauche die aktuelle zeit und davon muss ich aus abziehen die startzeit vom ersten
entry die startzeit vom erst oder gibt das sinn die startzeit vom ersten entry muss
ich abziehen in pixel wieder und dann nach links verschieben und und das sollte dann
eigentlich funktionieren wie mache ich das denn also irgendwie so ok also also wir machen
das wir probieren es gerade mal kurz kurz in line aus also pixel also sowas wie channel
epg entries epg entries der ist erste das erste epg eintrag und dann sagen start minus
leute ist new date ist das eben ist das sowas wie date now ist das sowas wie date now wenn
ich new date mache so und das jetzt und das jetzt geteilt durch 110 10.000 haben wir gesagt
nein cannot read properties start wie in property start warum nicht auf undy feind moment ich
habe irgendwo was wo es kein start gibt was mache ich denn hier überhaupt ich bin ich
bin ich bin total falsch monkeys wo bin ich denn hier gelandet bin ganz falsch das da
muss ich auch nicht hin also was mache ich denn hier überhaupt wie blödsinn hier muss
ich hin das sieht gut aus leute das sieht ziemlich gut aus 17 17 17 17 17 17 das sieht
gut aus 17.05 ist ein zweiter 17.10 ist noch ein zweiter das sieht gut aus das sieht so
aus als funktioniert er was hat er eigentlich hierfür schmerzen cannot read properties
of undy feind reading start jedes ding hat start defined wie kommt er auf die idee dass
es nicht so sein sollte aber vielleicht hat nicht jeder channel vielleicht hat nicht jeder
channel entries wie ging das so aber wenn nicht jeder channel entries hat ja stimmt
es hat nicht jeder channel entries dreißert passt nicht ganz doch doch alles gut ist sarah
connor nicht nicht die die von von terminator und warum hat die herzkraftwerke egal ich
hinterfragen fernsehprogramm nicht ok der kackt ab bei den sendern die keine pg haben
read properties undy feind start merkt nicht rum mann was ok sehr gut also wir haben sender
die haben kein epg tele 5 hat kein epg und mdr hd hat aus irgendwelchen gründen kein
epg soll mir recht sein brauche ich nicht den shit gut ich brauch es eh nie die tagesschau
mhr sind nicht exakt gleich ok zeigt mal kurz her heute tagesschau sind sie nicht ne sind
sie nicht gell die kunde jetzt kommen wir uns jetzt mal an ne die sind nicht genau gleich
warum nicht was ist das warum ist das hier verschoben was ist da los komm mal hier hier
siehst du es auch 18.15 warum warum ist das verschoben vielleicht vielleicht jetzt wirklich
wegen dem border das war kurz alles weg an den board super jetzt sehe ich ja nicht ohne
border wie mache ich denn jetzt ein inline inline border gibt es sowas auch noch aber
ich habe recht die sind nicht die sind nicht gleich das ist das ist doof vielleicht vielleicht
liegt auch am padding am padding liegt guck mal oder ist es jetzt gleich chat das liegt
am padding da drin jetzt ist gleich aber ich will ich will abstände dazwischen haben das
sieht sonst richtig richtig hängen geblieben aus will ich margin ich kann mir das immer
nicht merken margin versus padding css ok padding margin ne margin ist außen das will
ich net margin 2 ne ich will kein margin ich will muss man vielleicht muss man vielleicht
extra sowas hier nochmal machen nochmal irgendwie so innen drinne und jetzt class padding 2 dass
sich das außen nicht ändert das geht guckt leute das funktioniert ich weiß zwar nicht
warum aber das funktioniert guck mal rita ora etta eifeltau diese namen von diesen
sendungen ist genau allein mit dem rest so und jetzt kommt die probe aus example wenn
ich jetzt ein paar tage vorscrollen ist der kram immer noch allein ja ist er guck 2115
2115 25 ist weiter hinten 2110 ist weiter vorne ja das funktioniert das funzt leute
ich was meint ihr soll ich die sender raus filtern die kein epg haben oder oder soll
man die rendern und einfach sagen scheiß drauf ich meine es ist ja ein leeres feld
ja filtern aber auf der anderen seite ja wir können die raus filtern aber wir müssen
eh noch was machen also das hier mit dieser mit dieser länge ist ist ziemlicher ist ziemlicher
müll dass die dass die sender verschwinden das gefällt mir nicht wir müssen übrigens
noch die sender limitieren im backend fällt mir gerade ein wir müssen noch die müssen
noch die sachen limitieren und wieso funktioniert nicht an der rechten kante wo funktioniert
was nicht achso weil overflow weil das abgeschnitten wird dass das eigentlich geht die box bis
hier aber das wird abgeschnitten weil overflow hinten ist was auch sein muss dann sind die
gar nicht gleich breit welche sende die mit dem kecki die keine sender logos haben das
ist mdr oder sowas page pagi nation nie das muss man schon alles krollen so wie sieht
es eigentlich im firefox aus firefox kann diesen blur hier nicht oder wie das ist ja
schon mal doof die sekundenanzeige needy du hast recht die sekundenanzeige braucht man
wirklich nicht ich weiß aber nicht wie man den kram umformatiert wenn ich ehrlich bin
welche distro nutzt du manjaro mit i3 wm ist das hier ja also die doch kann firefox
ok firefox blur backdrop gucken wir mal backdrop filter mozilla aber das was ist das eigentlich
der komische trend die seiten statt mich auf deutsch zu stellen wenn man den browser auf
deutsch hat ich will die seiten nicht auf deutsch lesen browser support internet explorer
firefox kann das nicht moment das dürfte leute das ist das erste feature was ich jemals
gesehen habe was safari ios kann aber nicht firefox ich wusste nicht dass sowas gibt
normalerweise ist safari safari ios das schlimmste was es gibt aber diese kombination firefox
kann was nicht was safari ios kann das habe ich noch nie gesehen ok stimmt apple steht
auf blur ja das kann sein ok wenn das im firefox nicht funktioniert leute ich glaube dann lassen
wir das ganze geblurr mal kurz hallo wir lassen das ganze geblurr mal kurz und lassen das
ganze geblurr mal kurz und lassen das ganze geblurr mal kurz und lassen das ganze geblurr
mal kurz und lassen das ganze geblurr mal kurz und lassen das ganze geblurr mal kurz
muss was du musst im firefox die flex setzen er du meinst in den browser settings nicht
im css flex will ich da nicht muss so funktionieren das niemand setzt würden flex dass da was
das ist was sie da die derzeit die laufende sendung unter die sendung geschoben mit was
damit gar nicht was jetzt gerade läuft
Naja, jetzt läuft eindeutig Store and Kids Labor.
Du hast recht, das ist nicht so schön.
Man müsste das ganze noch ein bisschen weniger schiften, sodass es gleich inlined ist, aber
dann wieder ein Stück rausgeschoben wird.
Also im Endeffekt, anstatt hier durch 10.000 zu rechnen, könnte man dann im Ende, wenn
man das ausgerechnet hat, könnte man plus 400 machen oder so.
Ja, guckt jetzt sieht man was Sache ist.
Also das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Es müsste eine Art Strich geben, ja, man müsste hier anzeigen was es ist, ja.
Aber jetzt sieht man, guckt mal, jetzt sieht man was aktuelles, jetzt sieht man was aktuelles.
Da muss ich mir ein bisschen was schöneres ausdenken.
Ja, das allein auf die rechte Kante, ich weiß es nicht genau, wie man das, wie man das gescheit
machen könnte.
Da müsste ich was überlegen.
Aber das ist ja schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Jetzt sieht man alle Sendungen, außer, ah ne, haha, man sieht nicht alle Sendungen.
Aber das wird nicht funktionieren.
Guckt mal, das rein logisch gesehen kann das nicht funktionieren.
Stellt euch mal vor, hier läuft eine drei Stunden lange Sendung.
Man müsste den Text, wisst ihr was man machen muss?
Man müsste den Text eigentlich rechts alignen, dass man noch Chancen hat den zu sehen.
Aber das ist schon ein bisschen eklig.
Plexepg, da hab ich schon ein Bild von, ja.
So ungefähr, so ungefähr sollte es am Ende auch mal werden, genau.
Ja, so was hier machen müssen wir auch noch anzeigen, ja.
Wobei stimmt, man könnte den Hintergrund vom aktuellen machen.
Man könnte den Hintergrund von dem was aktuell läuft machen, tatsächlich.
Wir sollen nicht die ganze Zeit anzeigen hover, weil auf mobile hover nicht funktioniert.
Aber das an sich finde ich ist eine gute Idee, mit dem einfärben des aktuellen, das, das
können wir machen.
Das, das können wir machen, also sprich, wir brauchen E.
Wir brauchen E.
Was für den, für den Hintergrund.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es nennen soll.
Background.
Get, get background, mir fällt grad nichts anderes ein, get background, weil ich muss
ja noch nach den Genres gucken, ich will den Kram ja nach verschiedenen Genres einfärben
noch.
Also das aktuelle, das aktuelle färben wir mit einer bestimmten Farbe ein und den Rest
färben wir nach Genres ein, das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Also hier muss dann übrigens der Button hin für Aufnahme läuft.
Was meint ihr, ist das groß genug oder sollte ich den Kram noch ein bisschen größer machen?
Aber ich glaube, das lässt sich eigentlich gut bedienen, oder auf dem Desktop lässt
es sich gut bedienen, auf dem Tablet sieht es auch ok aus, das ist eigentlich genau richtig,
ja.
Das muss nicht höher sein, das passt so.
Sieht bestimmt auch gut aus, wenn du die Programmblöcke ein bisschen breiter machst.
Das ist schwierig, die Programmblöcke breiter zu machen, weil dann scrollst du dich ja tot
und, und das Problem ist, guck mal, die Sendung geht 50 Minuten, die geht nur 5 Minuten und
die geht 50 Minuten.
Wenn ich das jetzt noch breiter mache, dann hast du Sendungen, die eineinhalb Stunden
gehen, ist dann irgendwie ewig, ewig weit, ja.
Also ich meine, man könnte, man könnte zum Beispiel, man könnte irgendwie sagen durch
1000, dann hat man so einen Sekunden, so, und jetzt, anstatt noch mal durch 10 einfach
nur durch 5 machen.
Was machst du mit den kurzen Sendungen, ja gut, da kannst du draufklicken.
Guck mal, jetzt hast du ein bisschen mehr Platz, jetzt hast du ein bisschen mehr Platz, aber
jetzt hast du halt auch eineinhalb, guck mal, jetzt sind halt auch eineinhalb Stunden Sendung
massiv lang.
Oder findet ihr das besser so?
Weiß nicht.
Äh, das Alignment, Leute, vergesst, das Alignment stimmt damit nicht mehr.
Das vergesst, das Alignment stimmt nicht mehr, kann man vergessen, geht nicht.
Warum stimmt das, warum stimmt das Alignment hier nicht mehr?
Moment, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, ob das daran liegt oder woanders, äh, da sind
wir.
Äh, Hover gibt's auf dem Tablet nicht.
Na, wenn man draufklickt, kommt eh, also wenn man draufklickt, kommt eh die komplette Info
zur Sendung.
Doch, das Alignment, okay, das Alignment funktioniert anscheinend bloß in 10er-Schritten.
Ach, ich hab unten noch die alte Rechnung, stimmt, warte mal, hier hab ich, wo hab ich
die alte Rechnung?
Da!
Okay, es.
Ja, guck, jetzt ist das Alignment wieder korrekt.
Jetzt ist das Alignment richtig, also was, was findet ihr besser, das, wenn da mehr Platz
ist, aber ich, ganz ehrlich, ich find das ein bisschen, wobei man hat das ja, man hat
das ja meistens so, na, jetzt passt, jetzt passt halt mehr hin, ich mein, das, das ist
Lotto, ja?
Ich mein, 5-Minuten-Sendungen kriegen wir da nie richtig rein, wenn wir das so skalieren,
dass man 5-Minuten-Sendungen sieht, dann ist, dann ist eine Sendung, 3 Tage scrollen, bis
die, bis die durch ist, ja?
Aber so hat man wahrscheinlich zum, guck mal, das hier, das wird man nie erkennen, diese
1-Minuten-Blöcke.
Du musst die Timeline dynamisch skalieren, du meinst, je größer man das Fenster macht,
umso, ja, okay, das, das können wir machen, das können wir tatsächlich machen, das dürfte
sogar relativ einfach sein.
Dass die Sachen nur da gestreckt sind, wo es nötig ist, aber dann, dann, dann stimmt
das ganze Alignment nicht mehr, guck mal, wenn ich das hier jetzt strecken würde, zum
Beispiel, ja?
Wenn ich das hier jetzt strecken würde, dann, dann ist, ist die Zeit hier oben 1730 und
dann hier 17.05, ja gut, das heißt, ich müsste gucken, boah, das ist dann aber 5-Header,
dann müsste ich gucken, habe ich das hier gestretched und dann müsste ich das überall
anders, was danach kommt, auf allen anderen Sendern auch, nö, nö, das ist mir, das ist
mir zu, das ist mir zu, 6-Header, also Hover gibt es nicht, aber du kannst draufklicken
für mehr Informationen, aber was wir machen können, ist, dass man das tatsächlich anpasst
anhand der Seitenbreite irgendwie, also sprich, dass wir irgendwie sowas machen hier wie Scale,
standardmäßig ist 5, das muss man eh noch, glaube ich, an anderer Stelle machen, weil,
das, also, also gerade hier das Inline ist nur wirklich sehr Painschampig gelöst, guckt
euch das mal an, das versteht doch kein Mensch, so, und jetzt könnte ich beispielsweise, wenn
ich die, die, die Seite rescale, wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste, wie das ging, Window,
nee, Svelte, Svelte, Window, On, Resize, so ging das, glaube ich, Resize, das können
wir mal, das können wir mal probieren, ups, nee, kann ich nicht, kann ich nicht einfach
das so machen, und das funktioniert, weil ich es auch Resize, wenn ich es auch einfach
Resize nenne, Resize, guckt mal, ob das jetzt funzt, ein bisschen langsam ist es, nee, okay,
nee, das funktioniert so nicht, mit dem Mausrad, das kann man sich dann später überlegen,
nee, nee, nee, aber hier, das funzt, okay, ja, jetzt könnte ich irgendwie anhand dieses
Resize Events, irgendwas, irgendwas checken, hatten wir da nicht letztens erst für irgendwas,
das programmiert, dass wir, ja doch, der Labelchamp hatte das doch, Leute, wo ist der Labelchamp,
Labelchamp, Web, da ist er doch, da haben wir doch Resize, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo,
hier, handle Resize, stage Resize, window inner width, sondern hatten wir irgendwo, check
breakpoint, default config return window inner width passende, okay, da kann man nämlich
die breakpoints checken, da kann ich dann sagen, wenn es auf dem Tablet ist, dann so,
wenn es sonst wie sich so, also, window inner width, der Preischamp, den habe ich abgeschaltet,
das konnte ich den Crawler nicht mal gescheit aktualisieren, so, guckt mal, oder, oder,
wisst ihr was, man rechnet das einfach durch 100, guckt mal, das müsste, das müsste eigentlich,
das müsste eigentlich komplett reichen, oder, Resize und jetzt sagen wir einfach scale, scale
gleich, bam, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert, ja, so ungefähr, guckt
mal, jetzt ist die Sportschau riesengroß, wenn ich klein mache ist die Sportschau, äh,
okay heute, okay heute, heute ist jetzt so groß und, und wenn ich es ganz groß mache
ist heute, äh, nicht wirklich größer, oder, ich glaube der checkt das nicht, weil es dynamisch
ist, ich glaube der, der, ähm, ich glaube der, der evaluiert das nicht neu, das ist
nicht, nicht, nicht dynamisch, der checkt nicht, der rechnet das hier nicht neu aus
an der Stelle, weil sich das ändert, da weiß ich jetzt aber gerade nicht wie man das dynamisch
hinkriegen, das müsste ich, das müsste ich da neu, neu berechnen lassen, weiß ich, das
machen wir jetzt nicht, Leute, das, wir machen jetzt auch was sinnvolles, genau das muss
reactive sein, ich bin mir grad nicht sicher, wie ich das gebacken krieg, dass es reactive
ist, wahrscheinlich, doch ich weiß es, ich weiß es, ich müsste, wahrscheinlich müsste
ich das irgendwie so machen, äh, wie war die sonntags dafür, äh, ne, ne, ne, ne, du
musst dich einfach so, du musst so, so musst du machen, glaube ich, scale gleich fünf,
so dann, jetzt weiß ich nicht ob es checkt, ne noch nicht, so du musst, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ehrlich gesagt, ne, ne, ne, dollars, ne, ne im template, du meinst dem HTML, ne,
das wäre nur mit nem store, ach keine Ahnung, Leute, keine Ahnung, scheiß drauf, das bleibt
jetzt so, das bleibt jetzt so, wie wir es vorher gemacht haben, das überleg ich mir
dann, wie wir es machen, das ist jetzt nicht akut, dass das, dass das skaliert, Alter,
jetzt mal, wir machen lieber noch was sinnvolles, also wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, ähm,
also genau, also bisschen langsam ist es, oder, ich mein guck mal, bisschen lahm ist
es, aber gut, mein der rendert ja auch, genau, jetzt weiß ich wieder was ich machen wollte,
der rendert ja 24 Tage EPG aktuell, braucht ja kein Mensch, keine 24 Tage EPG, ne, ne
Patrick, das ist glaub ich nicht richtig, eine Woche reicht ja, eine Woche hab ich auch
standardmäßig drin, ähm, also, das, das, das müssen wir, das müssen wir beschneiden,
MonkaS, du hast aus der Doku nachgestellt, also was muss man machen, das funktioniert
doch im Leben so nicht, also so, mein, das ist ok, das, das, das, das kenn ich, ja, so,
das ist, das ist, dass es Reactive ist an den Stellen, genau, das, das kenn ich, das
kenn ich, so, ähm, aber, das bezieht sich eigentlich auf die rechte Seite Reactive machen,
also eigentlich bezieht sich das auf die Seite, das ist nicht scale is Reactive, sondern scale
is Reactive befüllt, also hier könnte ich beispielsweise was machen, was dynamisch ist,
und dann würde das befüllt werden, also es ist von rechts nach links eigentlich, nicht
von links nach rechts, ja gut, was ich machen könnte ist, das würde funktionieren, und
jetzt würde ich mitkriegen wenn sich scale ändert, guck, jetzt würde ich mitkriegen
wenn sich scale ändert, aber die Seite evaluiert das ja nicht neu, guck, jetzt krieg ich das
mit wenn sich scale ändert, aber das ändert ja nicht daran, dass der Kram hier neu evaluiert
wird, da muss ich mir erst überlegen wie ich das, wie man das, wie man das richtig
macht, da bin ich grad bisschen, also da bin ich grad bisschen ahnungslos, wobei funktioniert
das, das verschieben funktioniert doch schon oder, das was nicht funktioniert, Leute das
was nicht funktioniert ist mein hässliches inline gedöns hier, das funktioniert nicht,
das da funktioniert nicht, also nennen wir das einfach irgendwie off offset oder sowas,
start offset, so das, das müsste funktionieren, start offset, ja das müsste funktionieren,
so und da übergeben wir jetzt den channel und da machen wir dieses hässliche konstrukt
rein, so und nun start offset, channel, return, oh alter das sieht ja, das sieht ja so hässlich
aus jetzt schon, ich weiß gar nicht was da passiert, aber scheint zu funktionieren oder,
ok nice, ja funktioniert oder, ich, wobei, es funktioniert mehr als vorher auf jeden
fall, weil es wird beim resize geht das nichts kaputt, aber wirklich gut funktioniert es
immer noch nicht, das ist mir jetzt zu sixhead und wie kannst du vom fernseher auf das signal
vom tv header zugreifen, ich hab ein android tv mit kodi und das hat den ganz normalen
empfänger für den ganz normalen tv header entkleint und denkt dran ja committen machen
wir gleich, so wir machen mal ein commit sonst vergesse ichs wieder, wir machen mal kurz
zwischenseitig ein commit, git status, boah wir haben da ganz schön viel geändert, moment,
warum sind da so sachen drin, ach nee passt so alles gut, kein mist geedit, git add alles
hinzufügen, git commit a-m und jetzt brauchen wir eine massive nice commit message, keck
bye, nee komm wir machen was gescheites, wer ist der mvp des streams gewesen, keine ahnung,
beizweige ist immer mvp, edit web app, wurscht, push, sehr schön, so jetzt haben wir zumindest
schonmal zwischendurch gepusht, wo blors, wo blors, git hub, wo ist es, epg champ vor 22
sekunden, ok nice, jetzt hab ich zwar, run, backend, start, run, open, ach nee wir haben
es ja schon, ok also sag mal ein geschwindigkeitsrekord, ein geschwindigkeitsrekord gewinnts nicht ja,
muss man sagen, aber der mist braucht halt eine weile bis es rendert, wie bist du auf
wo blors gekommen, naja gar nicht wirklich, ich hab mir den account für twitch erstellt
damals bevor ich selbst streamen wollte, so wir müssen den kram noch hier beschränken
wie viele tage epg, ich überleg gerade wie würde man das jetzt gescheit machen, wir
können alles aussortieren, ah ich hab ne idee, ich hab ne idee was wir machen, wir sortieren
einfach alle events aus die nach 7 tagen starten, also sagen wir epg, epg, ich kann ja mal schreiben
gerade ist vorbei, where, epg, start, ach moment hab ich das noch nicht umgewandelt, naja dann
machen wir das nachher, channel, hier machen wir das, hier machen wir das, where, epg, start,
start ist größer als datetime now plus 7 tage, so und jetzt haben wir nur 7 tage epg,
schau mal warum kommt da immer ne 5 raus, ach ich hab noch was vergessen wisst ihr warum
das so langsam ist, oh ich noob, der render das doppelt aktuell, der render das serverseitig
und kleinseitig, weil ich das dumm gemacht hab, äh, wait a minute, äh, mein irgendwas
hab ich hier falsch gemacht, ach moment, wo start nicht größer, wo start kleiner 7 tage
ist, kann nicht funktionieren, so ok, jetzt sollte es auf jeden fall schon mal ne ganze
ecke schneller sein gleich, es ist ein bisschen schneller, aber wisst ihr was ich machen muss,
ähm, ich muss dem sagen, dass der serverseitig nix rendern soll, oder aber dass er kleinseitig
nix rendern soll, eins von beidem, wobei mir ist es lieber, der macht das gar nicht, mein
warum soll der serverseitig das komplette ding rendern, das ergibt ja keinen sinn, gerade
weil serverseitig bei mir auf dem linux receiver läuft, das darf der schön frontendmäßig
machen, ähm, so, labelchamp, web, ja wir wollen nix, hooks hier, wir wollen ausschalten
dass der serverseitig was rendert, wo muss das hin, nach source, hooks.js, so, oder,
lip, source, ja, ok wunderbar, so, und diese magic schaltet jetzt aus, dass der serverseitig
was rendert, perfekt, geht auch schon schneller, naja, die zeiten passen nicht, warum, doch,
die zeiten passen, nee, wait a minute, die zeiten passen nicht, es ist 19.45, 18.15
müsste 20.15 sein, oh nein, zeitzonenprobleme, bitte nicht, da kümmere ich mich jetzt nicht
rum, das war mal das hier, zeitzonenprobleme gebe ich mir heute nicht mehr, nicht nach
drei stunden, vielleicht sollte ich es einfach als unix time zurückgeben, alles, ich frag
mich wo das herkommen kann, ich mein, meine vm hat die richtige zeitzone, mein browser
hat die richtige zeitzone, mein linux receiver hat die richtige zeitzone und tv hat dann
die gleiche zeitzone, warum ist das, das ist utc, das ist utc, warum ist das utc und warum
ist das nicht, der denkt, dass das utc ist, hier, guck mal, der, der, der denkt, dass,
dass utc ist, kann man nämlich eine zeitzone angeben, ach du scheiße, js new date, time
zone, was zum, what, nein, das mach ich nicht, was zum, ich will nicht, ich will, ist in
meiner zeit, ok, das müssen wir anders machen, das müssen wir anders machen, wir müssen
dafür sorgen, wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass der, dass das backend, das backend muss diesen
krempel hier, richtig, richtig übertragen, oder datetimefunctions verwenden, ja, das
ist wahrscheinlich besser, der muss diesen kram hier serialisieren mit, wir gucken mal
kurz, was da, was da für ne curl, was da zurückkommt, epg, epg, hier, start, ja natürlich,
2015, ich muss mal gucken, wo es falsch ist, wo ist es denn falsch, ok, was läuft denn
heute abend, erstes, also wir können, ich kann auch hier mal im epg gucken, also wer
stirbt, dem glaubt man nicht, läuft heute im ersten, oder, ard, das erste, wann läuft
das heute, wahrscheinlich 20, wahrscheinlich 20.15, ok, also, läuft, 19.5, ne, 18.5, ok,
der überträgt das schon falsch, der überträgt das schon falsch, ähm, from unix time seconds,
warum ist das falsch, muss ich vielleicht hier sowas sagen wie local, ah, local datetime,
habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich Zeit, dass ich die pure Existenz von Zeitzonen verabscheue,
einfach alles in utc und gut ist, wen juckt's, so, ja, das sieht jetzt schon besser aus,
guckt mal, das sieht schon besser aus, 20.15, so und jetzt, mal gucken wie weit das geht,
Moment, ich muss mal kurz das Datum noch mit einplenden, dass ich checke, gibt's hier auch
sowas wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, day, oder so, woher weiß ich was da rein kann, day, day,
true digit, keine Ahnung ob das funktioniert, ey, tatsächlich, so, vierter, wie weit geht
denn der epg, bis elfter, sind sieben Tage, ja, das ist richtig, das ist ok, also sieben
Tage epg, ist richtig, alles in Ordnung, jo, also das, das funst, so, das ist richtig
aligned, warum verschwinden die Dinger da unten immer noch, ah, weil wir das noch nicht
gefixt haben, ja, wie kriegen wir das denn hin, dass der Krempel überhaupt, jaja, deswegen
läuft auch um 20.15 nichts, weil meine Zeitzone falsch war, so, also, wie kriegen wir das
hin, dass der Kram da sticky bleibt, das funktioniert wahrscheinlich nur, so, das ist ein diff pro
channel, RTL 2 20.14 sieht komisch aus, nö, das ist anscheinend so, guck mal, wie hast
du das gemacht, dass das Backend nicht mit dem Frontend Combined läuft, hä, ich kenn's
irgendwie nur, dass da dann beides in ein, du meinst pap, pap ist das einzige was mir
einfällt, wo man zumindest historisch gesehen html und pap code alles in einem Pfeil geschrieben
hat, ansonsten außer diesem klassischen uralt pap zeug fällt mir nicht so viel ein wo man
das so macht, ich mein es gibt noch sowas wie razor pages oder so, da machst du auch
ein bisschen dotnet, server-seitig rendering, flask ist das frontend in einem, das heißt
du schreibst html in python oder wie, ja gut, kann man machen mit irgendwelchen templates
server-seit rendering, ja, das geht, ja, server-seit rendering kannst du machen, das tut, aber
ja, ja stimmt, also ja, keine ahnung, es war eine klein-zeit anwendung mit javascript
kram, ich mein ob du jetzt javascript und html im template machst oder extra, ich persönlich
finde es von der handhabung her schöner, ich will das auch gar nicht server-seitig
renderen, weil wenn ich server-seitig diesen kram hier rendere, da ist ja mein linux-receiver
komplett überfordert und ins weltkit hab ich direkt abgeschaltet, weil ich will nicht
dass er das server-seitig rendert, wenn er das server-seitig, guck mal, mein desktop-browser
braucht aktuell um das zu rendern bestimmt 3 sekunden, weil das halt ein riesen ding
ist ja, bis das hier alles gerendert ist und wenn ich das auf dem linux-receiver server-seitig
render, ich glaube dann, dann kackt mir das ding ab, das wird, das schaltet sich einfach
aus, ok, also jetzt lasst uns noch mal ein bisschen was sinnvolles machen, hübsch machen
können wir es ja immer noch, also hier oben muss noch ne anzeige gehen mit der zeile,
ne wir wollten einfärben leute, das hab ich ganz vergesst, wir wollten einfärben, was
gerade aktuell ist, das, das machen wir jetzt, hier, das da einfärben, was gerade aktuell
ist, schneller bekommen wir das auch hin, schneller bekommen wir das hin, wenn wir das
nicht alles in einem machen würden, sondern quasi einmal abfragen pro channel und danach
und nach rendern, das würde wahrscheinlich schneller gehen, zeitleiste, ja zeitleiste
muss oben auf jeden fall hin, wobei eine zeitleiste brauchen wir weniger, wir brauchen eine tagesleiste
da oben, man die zeit sieht man ja hier, aber man weiß nicht welcher tag ist, also man braucht
auf jeden fall eine tagesanzeige und das hier, ich mach jetzt mal was anderes, w, ne flex,
keine ahnung, 65.000, bam, backgroundworker, na fürs rendern, das rendern braucht ja lang,
das rendern kannst du ja mit backgroundworker nicht wirklich beschleunigen, 70.000, dann
verschwindet der kram wenigstens nicht, ok, das müssen wir auf jeden fall noch schöner
machen, 100% geht nicht, 80.000, 90.000, keine ahnung, wie viel dahin muss, immer nur einen
tag rendern, aber das ist ziemlich langsam, da kannst du nicht so schnell scrollen, der
flippt dir aus, sag mal, interessiert den das nicht wirklich, doch das ist ok, das funktioniert,
90.000 war nicht genug oder was, 100.000 pixel, was weiß ich wie breit das sein muss, 150.000
pixel, das müssen wir irgendwie anders hinbekommen, das kannst du heute nicht sein, 110 view width,
das wird nicht funktionieren und overflow scroll will ich nicht, nee das bringt nix,
das dachte ich mir, was mal 10, was 100 mal, so, ja aber, keine ahnung, wo soll der wissen,
das ist im prinzip das gleiche gerate, das gleiche gerate wie ich mit pixel mache, doch
ich kann sagen autofit content das problem ist nur wenn ich das mache, ich das mache,
dann in den zeilen wo leer ist, verschwindet das sticky gleich, weil es ja nicht breiter
hat, oder, warte mal, kann ich nochmal einen diff außen drum herum machen und dann sagen,
so was, ah, ah, pfeil fett, ich weiß zwar nicht genau ob das die beste lösung ist,
aber das funktioniert, guck mal da, es sieht ein bisschen hässlich aus ehrlich gesagt
hier hinten oder, aber gut, und so dieses doppelt überlagerte mit dem rand sieht auch
nicht gerade hübsch aus, können wir nicht dazwischen noch ein bisschen platz machen,
also dass man zum beispiel sagt, hier ist ja die channel, das ist ja quasi diese eine
zeile, können wir nicht sowas sagen wie margin bottom run oder sowas, also schöner ist das
jetzt auch nicht oder, padding links und rechts geht nicht, dann stimmen die zeiten nicht,
ja genau wir gucken uns das ab, das ist besser, ich mein das ist immerhin so, so ist zumindest
schon mal besser als am anfang oder, wobei das sieht kacke aus wenn zwischen den senderlogos
luft ist, ne ne ne ne, ne das sieht kacke aus, ja sieht schon kacke aus, so, jetzt machen
wir noch was was wir die ganze zeit schon mal wollten, nämlich das aktuelle einfärben,
wir klauen uns wirklich, wir klauen uns irgendwo ein bisschen design davon, ja, also das aktuelle
das aktuelle einfärben, jetzt testen wir mal ob das funktioniert, bg gray 500, get background
background, background, where is background, background, da, da ist der background, weg damit,
get background, ok, so das sieht jetzt nicht schön aus, aber das passen wir jetzt gleich
an, also if epg entry, wenn start größer, also wir brauchen sowas wie now, now gleich
new date, so also wenn start größer now ist und now kleiner epg entry stop, dann läuft
die sendung gerade, sagt wenn ich blödsinn mache, weil sowas vertubt man sich mal schnell,
so sehen wir jetzt ja auch gleich schon ob es funktioniert, wir sehen gar nichts, was
so, was, wie kann es keinen start haben, achso, dann sollte es vielleicht doch übergeben,
was soll denn dieser line break da drin jetzt, ja, das sieht gut aus, also von der Idee her
passt das, er markiert das was angesagt ist, ok, also return, daran sieht man aber auch
dass man den kram unbedingt noch ein bisschen verschieben muss, ja, weil das ist total,
das ist total raus, raus, raus geschoben, ähm, sollte das nicht genau umgedreht sein,
äh, what, wait a minute, sollte das nicht genau umgedreht sein, pg entry start ist größer
now und stop ist größer, ne, moment, kleiner, ne, warte mal, now ist kleiner
als stop, ne, schwachsinn, start muss kleiner sein als now, ja, ne, sag mal, doch, ne, ist
richtig, ist richtig so, was hatte ich denn vorher für ne hintergrundfarbe, 200, sowas,
ne was ist das für ne ewig lange sendung hier, sommer in griechenland, das hört ja gar nicht
mehr auf, das ist ja 3km lang, kurz scale, bisschen hochschalten, da fehlt noch ein margin
left, na ich hab ganz viel margin left, aber wir müssen, wir dürfen es nicht so weit verschieben,
wir müssten das, nochmal irgendwie plus 400 oder so machen, ja, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
weit, ja ungefähr so, so ungefähr so, wie ist das denn im kodi gelöst eigentlich, da
kann ich einfach zurückscrollen, ne, wie haben die das hier denn gemacht, ja hier sieht man
das auch nicht, aber hier kann ich einfach zurückscrollen, hm, das ist aber im browser
nicht richtig zu handhaben, weil dann hab ich auf einmal ne scrollbar, die in der mitte
anfangen muss oder so, ja wenn man draufklickt sieht man es ja bei mir auch, ja, wenn man
dann draufklickt, das ist kein ding, aber zumindest das geht schon ungefähr in die
richtige richtung, die, ich mein ich könnte einfach aus der vergangenheit noch ein bisschen
was, ne da kann man auf dem tablet nicht richtig scrollen, das backt dann wieder mit touch wenn
man irgendwelche nachladenden dinger hat, das ist so doch eigentlich ganz ok, so wir
brauchen eine gute farbe, was ist denn eine gute farbe für aktiv, was, was, wie macht
es blacks, wir gucken uns das jetzt einfach ab, wirklich viel hübscher ist das jetzt
aber auch nicht, grün, ne das muss, das muss schon irgendwie neutral sein, ich mein man
könnte vielleicht das aktuelle opacity irgendwie 90 oder so, agile pink, ne ne, hab ich das
falsch geschrieben, opacity 90, doch richtig, ach ne, ach quatsch, das ist doch blödsinnig
so, das funktioniert nicht so ganz wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab, can't wait, opacity
ist gut, ok opacity ist gut, aber vielleicht, aber vielleicht nicht so krass opacity oder,
du kannst beispiel, jaja ich brauch inspiration, du, du, du, du, du, das müssen wir glaub
ich noch z index machen für die z 30 oder so, dass die sticky dinger oben sind, ja exzellent,
so hast du es in der mobile app, zeig mal her, testen wir jetzt mal, hoffentlich kommt
jetzt kein rickroll oder pornbilder wenn ich rumscolle oder so, das ist gar nicht schlecht,
hobs jetzt ich lösch grad irgendwas, speicher mir das mal, was jetzt, funktioniert das auch
gescheit, also wenn ich da scrolle auf mobile fühlt sich das dann auch an, ne guck mal hier,
die lädt das schon nach, fühlt sich das dann auch an wie mobile scrolling also sprich
von der geschwindigkeit her und vom nachlaufen her und so oder muss man das alles selbst
machen mit dem speed, aber das ist schon mal guck mal, da dreh ich durch wenn ich so scrollen
muss, guck mal der lädt immer nach und jetzt kann ich jetzt weiter scrollen, oh ne da krieg
ich anfälle, ich will huge scrollen können, ne endless scroll gibt es bei mir nicht, ich
werd nicht endless scrolled, kann man opacity 150 machen was passiert dann, sicher dass
das nachlädt, ja, weil sobald du ein bisschen gewartet hast ist es dann auf einmal wieder
zum weiter scrollen, so weil wir müssten eigentlich den ganzen krempel noch einfärben je nach
genre, je nach genre das, der epg sendung, hab ich hier, hab ich diesen kram überhaupt
schon irgendwo drinne, das genere, wo ist das genere, da, ne und mit endless scroll hast
du dann auch das problem dass die scroll behalten teilweise, wobei das ist ja mittlerweile geht
das, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob das eine gute idee ist, so genre haben wir doch
am start, wie krieg ich denn das da rein, so programm, wo sind wir denn hier, da epg event,
gibt es da ein genre, nein gibt es nicht, prop, ring, genre, ja ja null alles klar wenn
es nix gibt, ja ich muss mal gucken, jetzt muss erstmal die basic funktion rein, so also
das genre ist leer standardmäßig und wir setzen das jetzt hier, ist das hier genre,
vielleicht, aber moment, das frage ich das gar nicht ab, aber ich frage das grad gar
nicht ab, tv epg event, ich frag das überhaupt nicht, ok das ist natürlich doof, wie sieht
denn das aus, so eine antwort, auch noch ein array, alter was denken die sich denn, hat
eine sendung mehrere genre IDs oder wie, ja also das ist das ist genre 2 und 160 und 320
weil, weil es ein drama show comedy ist, gibt es sowas, warum hat es mehr als eins, come
on bruh, was soll das, warum muss das ein array sein, das macht das handling doch wieder
total kaputt, action thriller, grimmydrama, ja aber das ist doch, das gibt es doch schon
als eine kategorie, ok also, prop, int wahrscheinlich, genere, jawoll, ok, jetzt sollte das serialisiert
werden, hoffe ich, das heißt ich kann hier hingehen und sagen, genre, first, ah ne das
funktioniert nicht richtig, das ist müll, da muss ich mir was anderes überlegen, genre
gleich, also ich hab hier das ja schonmal in weißer voraussicht gestern gebaut, dass
ich mir das von der api abfragen kann, hier, jetzt kriege ich, jetzt kriege ich ein, jede
menge key value dinger zurück, mit einer id und einem name, das heißt ich kann jetzt
an der stelle gucken, ob, das link wird auch langsam ein bisschen viel hier an der stelle,
jetzt kann ich an der stelle gucken, ob es, ob das genre, also sprich, ob, boah, was,
find, ne, first, id, gleich, gleich, igitt, das ist ja abfack, first or default, alles
klar, no one is default value is null, funktioniert nicht, ok, warum nicht, weil nullable, ach
mensch, ok, ähm, wo sind wir, gleich, ja, array, empty, wunderbar, int, dann ist halt
nix drin, soll mir auch recht sein, was hat er denn für schmerzen, ich kann, u long, bitte
was, wer zum, n long, warum, wie viele genre it's gibt's denn bitteschön, einmal die
gesamte weltbevölkerung oder, ne, die null gehört dahin, weil wenn es nichts hat, wenn
nichts gesetzt ist, ähm, dann soll es null, null nehmen, also, mal angenommen, es ist
eine sendung ohne genre id, warum ist das dann long, von wo überhaupt, von, long, long
id, hier, weg, weg damit, ist kein long, ist ein int, fertig, immer noch net, ähm, was
mach ich, also, ok, ok, langsam, langsam, also, id, id, so, id ist ein int, oder, int,
genau, sehr schön, wir leben 2022, da kennt jeder eher, so, und die id soll, ist doch
richtig, was hat er denn für schmerzen, ach so, ha, moment, so muss es ja auch sein,
name, null, jaja, jetzt, jetzt ist gut, aber jetzt mag er nicht, weil es könnte null sein,
warum könnte es null sein, es kann überhaupt nicht null sein, warum muss ich jetzt noch
first or default machen, monkaS, das kann man doch irgendwie schöner schreiben, das
ist, das ist eklig, moment, nee, nee, nee, nee, das müssen wir anders machen, also genre,
ich weiß, dass null drinne ist, null, null ist auf jeden fall drinne, immer, das weiß
aber, dass die sharp compiler nicht, dass da null drinne ist, also null ist immer drinne,
kann ich ihm das irgendwie verklickern, kann ich ihm sagen, ich könnte ihm sagen, where,
where, null, ah, dann crashts, oder, first, boah, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, was hat er
denn für schmerzen jetzt, man hat ja keine schmerzen, aber, es funktioniert auch einfach,
guck mal meine ide will euch mal mehr overlays anzeigen, es ist broken, zeigt ihr da oben
irgendwas an, ach so, weil, weil first und nicht default ist, das ist mir zu viel link
in link geschachtelt jetzt, ich mein theoretisch, theoretisch müsste ich ja sowas machen können,
first or default, oder quasi ein leeres oder so, nee, nee, will er auch nicht, ok, ich
hab keine ahnung, wo der shit jetzt null sein kann, wie kann das, ah, ich weiß warum das
null sein kann, weil, weil, name, null sein, alter, das kann nicht null sein, wie soll
das null sein können, das kann nie null sein, aber ich geh davon aus, dass der, dass der
recht hat, die Analyse, ja, ach, das hier meint er kann null sein, oder was, monkaS,
man, hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf, deswegen kann das null sein, aber das kann kein null
sein, das ist immer, das ist immer was drin, ok, da ist er, da ist tatsächlich der mein,
das kann null sein, ah, nee, kann nicht null sein, sag ich doch, first or default, id und
gleich eins, hä, da merkt er jetzt nicht, dass es null sein kann, alles klar, ok, ja,
das leuchtet mir ein, dass es null sein kann, das, das verstehe ich jetzt ja, dass es null
sein kann, so, jetzt doch alles gut, genau so will ich das haben, nee, so will ich das
nicht haben, aber, jetzt, jetzt, hab ich eben gesagt, dass das nullabel sein kann, oder
was, ach so, nee, das soll nicht, das ist, das steht immer was drin, das, das liefert
die API so zurück, die API liefert im Zweifelsfall einen leeren String, aber nicht, nicht null,
übrigens, dass es im nächsten C Sharp gibt, so neues Feature, dass im nächsten C Sharp
kann man endlich sagen, lass mal auf, public record hack v, so, aktuell ist es so, wenn
ich irgendeine API hab, zum Serialisieren von dem, von dem Response Zeug, blub, so,
und jetzt sagt er mir, ah, aber Achtung, String könnte null sein, da musst du jetzt immer
aktuell sowas machen, wenn du sagst, nein, ich weiß, dass es kein null ist, aber es gibt
jetzt ein neues C Sharp Feature in Version 7, da kannst du sagen, require, require set,
oder require init, glaub ich, so, und dann, dann weiß der, dass es immer belegt wird beim,
beim, beim Zuweisen, und dann kannst du diesen Campbell sparen, nee, das hier wird nicht
rausgeschmissen, was rausgeschmissen wird, soweit ich weiß, ist das hier, was sie mal
zwischen, oder das hier, was sie mal zwischenzeitlich einführen wollten, da haben sie gesagt, nope,
diesen Mist brauchen wir nicht, haben sie, fand ich auch nicht schön, es war, ich mein,
du kannst das mit zwei Zeilen selber machen, so, und was, was stört ihn da jetzt eigentlich
genau dran, wenn ich das jetzt hier zuweise, jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich einfach, gell,
ja, weil ich gesagt habe, es kann nicht null sein, ja, dann ist doch alles gut, ja, hier
merkt er jetzt, dass es null sein kann, wenn ich jetzt hier sage, first, da sagt er A,
es könnte, ja, da sagt er jetzt A, okay, es könnte, es könnte null sein, weil, weil
das hier theoretisch leer sein kann, so, und ich weiß aber, dass die ID auf jeden Fall
drinne ist, ja, wenn ich crash das ganze, das ist okay, aber ich weiß, dass es drinne
ist, so, so Leute, es ist 17.53, es ist Zeit, dass ich was futtere, wir haben auch lang genug
jetzt, oh, von wegen, ich weiß, dass was drinsteht, null, Sequence Contains No Elements, und ich
hab noch, ich weiß, dass was drinsteht, es kann gar nicht anders sein, Pech gehabt, Sequence
Contains No Elements, so gut, okay, da bin ich mir doch nicht so sicher, dass es drinsteht,
es gibt tatsächlich, ach so, ja, das hier, ja, das kann natürlich tatsächlich sein,
oh, Default, ja, gibt es, kann ich nicht irgendwie einen Default Typ davon machen, das ist ja
ziemlich, ziemlich eklig, kann ich irgendwie einen Default machen oder so, ich mein, oder,
ich wollte gerade sagen, oder, du hast eigentlich recht, warte mal, nee, das hier ist das Problem,
das hier ist das Problem, es gibt tatsächlich Sachen, da ist kein Genre definiert, also
das hier ist eigentlich das Ding, First or Default, null, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, heute
geht's bald, geht mir auf den Sack, so, für heute reicht's, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt
funktioniert, hey, es funktioniert, das machen wir dann anders, das ist nicht schön, das
müssen wir ein bisschen aufdröseln, das ist zugeschachtelt, ja, da blickst du nicht mehr
durch langsam, Shapeshifter, danke für den Zap, ich Committe jetzt noch einmal und push
den Krempel, Git add minus a, Committe, ich war in der Science Kategorie, ist ja auch nicht
so verkehrt, Massive Cute Chat, so, bestes Committe, Bastard, so, also wenn sich das noch
mal das E-Line angucken will von heute, Wobblors, nicht Monarch S, was will er von mir, Cannot
Retrieve, nee, ihr müsst Wobblors EPG Champ, wir können einen Screenshot, Leute, wir machen
einen Screenshot rein, oder, mit dem Keg W drinne, komm, wir machen noch einen Screenshot
in die Readme, wir tun so, als ob es besser aussieht, als es eigentlich ist, ok, bevor
wir einen Screenshot machen, ich will das mit dem Genre, ok, das machen wir jetzt noch,
ok, funktioniert das, es ist egal ob das hier schön ist oder nicht, das juckt mich nicht,
funktioniert das denn hier mit dem Genre überhaupt jetzt noch, Log, habe ich da jetzt irgendeinen
Genre ein, what, achso, Run, was, Backend, Run, wir machen jetzt noch einen Screenshot
rein, und am Mittwoch das mit dem Screenshot funktioniert, also eine Sache machen, so, haben
jetzt die Entries, haben die Entries da jetzt einen ordentlichen Genre Eintrag, News, Current
Affairs, alles klar, ok, wir könnten aber auch, das kleinseitig machen, auf die Sendung
klicken, noch nicht, das bauen wir noch, das machen wir noch, du kannst das anklicken,
da kommen die Details und dann kannst du auch auf Aufnahmeplanen drücken und sowas, also,
so get background, ok, also wenn es jetzt played, dann wird es diese Farbe, und ansonsten, if,
else if, wenn EPG Entry Genre contains, contains News, übrigens noch eine kleine Kleinigkeit,
too lower, please, wobei, das können wir im Frontend machen, hatte eigentlich hier nichts
zu suchen, too, ist es too lower case in JavaScript, ne, includes ist es, oder, includes, ah, ok,
ok, was für eine Farbe für News, Leute, Tailwind, willst du die Sendung komplett einfüllen,
sorry, ja, oder baust du ein Pilz ein, ein was, baust du Pilze, ach so, du meinst, dass
es da einfach ein Kringel dran gibt mit einer Farbe oder so, hm, weiß nicht, ne, ich würd's
komplett einfärben, ok, background color, blau, ok, warte mal, colors, die haben noch
eine schöne Übersicht über die colors, hier, blau, blue, blue, 300 oder so, blue, ok, Nachrichten
Sendung sind blau, ja, sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus, Nachrichten Sendung sind blau,
ok, wir sollten mal kurz, mal ganz schnell alle Genres auflisten lassen, die wir überhaupt
sehen, oder, ich mein, wo, wo soll man wissen, was, was, was, was es uns alles gibt, also
each, wie machen wir das jetzt, wie lassen wir uns alle Genres auflisten, hab eine Idee,
wa, Set, Set, ne, Set, ne, wie geht das, Set, äh ja, geht doch, Autocomplete ist wieder
Massive-Pepega, alter, Set, äh, Add, und jetzt Epg Entry Genre, und jetzt sagen wir
Lock, Set, so, gucken wir mal, was da drin steht, also, 50 verschiedene Genres gibt's
hier, Football Soccer, all das machen wir jetzt, ok, ok, paar, paar Dinge, die, die gebräuchlich
sind, Movie Drama ist garantiert auch, kommt auch öfters vor, Movie, Movie Drama, Leute,
Movie Drama wird was, rot, keine Ahnung, hier, so, ähm, Education, das wird ein ganz schön
langes If, man könnte das auch in einer, in einer, in einem Dictionary machen, das
wird wahrscheinlich deutlich, deutlich, äh, schöner, vielleicht sollten wir das auch
anders machen, to lowercase, und diesen ganzen anderen Krempel schmeißen wir doch mal kurz
weg, so, das ist schon ein bisschen lesbarer, Switch, ah, so neumodischen Krempel da, so,
als If, Genre, aber sowas kann ich nicht in den Switch packen und das gehört da logisch
gesehen dazu, also News haben wir, so, Movie, Movie, Movie ist Red, ähm, News, was haben
wir als nächstes, Arts, Education, Education, Education ist, äh, Emerald, ich, ich denk
mir jetzt, ich denk mir einfach irgendwas aus, ja, in der Hoffnung das passt dann am
Ende, so, als nächstes Sports, Sports, Sports, ah, es ist ja, und jetzt muss man schon mehrere
Sachen machen, Sports, oder, oder, Soccer, ähm, Fußball, Krempel, Pink, aha, ok, Show,
Soap, Soap, Drama, Folklorik, das ist das gleiche wie Movie, Soap, ok, ähm, ich lass
mal kurz hier dahinter den Kram rendern, damit wir wissen was noch fehlt, EPG Entry, oha,
Detective Thriller, ok, auch, auch, alles sauber, Detective, ganz toll, man sieht, man sieht
das nicht, weil das sieht kacke aus, Genre, scheiß auf die Zeit, die Zeit braucht keiner,
wir brauchen nur Genre, so, also, ok, Dokumentation und Education ist ja, das geht ja, geht ja
schon, ich muss, äh, Doku, das aktuell laufende wird eingefärbt, doch, ach so meinste das,
ja, wir können es ja so machen, dass das aktuell laufende die gleiche Farbe kriegt,
aber ein bisschen dunkler oder so, also, dass man, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, ok, ah,
das muss ich, das muss ich am Ende, das muss ich am Ende machen, ja, ja, das machen wir,
das können wir einfach am Ende dann die Opacity ein bisschen runter setzen, genau, wir machen
die ein bisschen transparenter und dann das andere machen wir, ja, das passt schon, äh,
so, also, was haben wir als nächstes zu bieten, Social, Social kriegt das gleiche wie News,
irgendwelche komischen Sendungen, die keiner braucht, so, so, Sarah Connor, ach, das ist
nicht die aus Terminator, die singt was oder wie, ok, Rock Pop, das ist, haben wir, haben
wir sowas wie Entertainment oder sowas, Show, Show haben wir irgendwo, Show Game Show,
ok, perfekt, Show oder Rock, so, was ist das, das kriegen die Fuchsier, Quest Duell, ok,
die haben nix, die haben, die haben gar nix, die sind jebaited, jebaited, overrated, outdated,
die ARD hat's nicht nötig, dass man dort, äh, Genres setzt, kann man auch nicht erwarten
bei so viel Geld wie man bekommt, dass man da EPG Genres ordentlich setzt, das geht nicht,
so, was fehlt denn sonst noch, was ist denn das, bitte schön, Serious, Serious, Classical,
Glitches, Historical Movie, Drama, dann suchen wir doch einfach nach Drama, da haben wir beides
abgedeckt, so, exellent, ARDs, ARDs kriegt das gleiche wie Rock und Pop, so, das muss
nur für den Screenshot gut aussehen, den Rest, den Rest können wir, den Rest können
wir mal anders machen, Hauptsache das sieht für den Screenshot gut aus, Cooking, achja,
Cooking, Nature, Nature und Cooking brauchen wir noch, ähm, Violet, perfekt, Violet, Nature,
wobei Nature sollte eigentlich Grün sein, aber gut, ist jetzt schon belegt, für Education,
Cooking, wobei, Nature könnte das gleiche wie Education kriegen und Doku, ja, oh je,
Unexpected Talking, Leute, wo ist das, hier, ok, Pog, ok, komm, komm, ist auch fast, ist
auch fast alles schon, Religion, Comedy, Science Fiction, ok, Science Fiction ist das gleiche
wie Movie, Alter, das hätte ich ja nie gedacht, dass das so ein Abfuck ist, das zu machen,
Movie, hier, Monkeys, da drehst du ja durch bei Science, ok, gut, Comedy, ok, ok, ok,
ok, Alter, wie viel Zeug gibt's da nicht noch in einem besseren Zeitpunkt, wo das alles
schöne Farben hat, Film, Film gibt's auch noch, ok, die Dinger machen wir jetzt und
da mach ich einen Screenshot von und das reicht, ok, Rock, wo haben wir Rock, Rock ist, äh,
Musik und Movie, Movie kriegt noch Film, perfekt, so, jetzt ist so viel Rot, egal,
für den Screenshot muss es jetzt tun, das muss, für den Screenshot muss das jetzt
reichen, ja, exzellent, Screenshot, zack, doch, ich hab, natürlich hab ich einen Autoformater,
wie sollen da Kram sonst automatisch hier jetzt runter, runtergedings werden, doch,
doch, guck, Standard-Autoformater, das sieht halt auch im Autoformater hässlich aus, so,
jetzt haben wir hier ein Bild, Paint, wie, Screenshot nicht funktioniert, was soll das,
warum geht das Screenshot nicht, jetzt, Massive-Build, achso, ich bin in GitHub ja gar nicht eingeloggt,
aber ich kann pushen, aber ich kann pushen, so, alles klar, so, speichern wir das ganze
mal kurz, ähm, ok, Markdown, Read Me, Read Me, Read Me, alles klar, Open, ähm, Image,
ach Gott, wie ging das nochmal, Image in, so oder, Markdown Insert Image, das kann ich
mir immer nicht merken im Kopf, wie geht das, so, alles klar, perfekt, also, Screenshot und
jetzt heißt das Ding, ähm, Screenshot.jpg, alles klar, achso, ähm, Moment, wie, ok,
wie mache ich denn jetzt unter Linux ein Bild, mit dem Bild, mit aus der Kommandozeile, äh,
mache ich sehr selten, ach, ich bin auch doof, ich hab doch hier ein Screenshot Tool, Mann,
richtig hängen geblieben, äh, Select, Reach and Capture Mouse Pointer, no, save, ok, so
und das speichern wir jetzt in, ähm, ipgChamp, hier, nicht in log, Screenshot.jpg, alles
klar, gut, äh, jetzt muss man sich Vorschau anzeigen lassen, Preview von Markdown, Bäm,
da ist es, jetzt haben wir einen Massive Screenshot dabei, äh, in Shithub, jetzt Status, Add,
wat, add, hat aber funktioniert, äh, Comet, Pipeheader, so, beste Comet Message, alles
klar, so, jetzt gucken wir mal auf GitHub, wie sieht's aus, der ipgChamp hat ein Bild,
Bäm, das sieht doch jetzt gleich, soll ich mal was sagen, das sieht jetzt gleich viel
vertrauenswürdiger aus, dass man das verwenden will, weil es einen Screenshot drin hat, oder?
Ja, ich mag auch keine Repos ohne Screenshot, so, sehr gut, das ist doch für heute, was
ich meine, 4 Stunden, da hab ich meine, äh, Streamingpflicht getan, also was haben wir
denn hier, guck mal hier, 64% C-Sharp, der Rest ist JavaScript, ja, ergibt ja auch Sinn,
dieser Frontend-Teil wird noch den Backend-Teil, glaub ich, überholen, macht seriöser, ja,
die Startzeit wird nicht, oh, oh, das hab ich verkackt, die Startzeit sollte angezeigt
werden, Moment, Moment, ich muss den Screenshot updaten, ah, ich hab die Startzeit verkackt,
ähm, das hab ich ja nur temporär reingemacht, so, Genre soll wieder raus, da soll die Startzeit
hin, schauen wir noch, ich geh jetzt was essen gleich, hallo, ah, run, das machen wir gleich
was, was man normalerweise nicht macht, wir ermenden das Ganze, aber das, für das Genre
haben wir keinen Platz, wo war man denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben, hier oder hier?
Was sieht, was sieht denn gut aus, das hier, ha, das Vermächtnis der was, Sister, Zin-Zin-Zier,
ah, Moment, wie spricht man das aus, Sister-Zinzer, meine Güte, so, gut, das ist ein schönes
Screenshot hier, Screenshot, Kloster, aha, Mönch, Mönchstelz, wenn's Kloster ist,
sozusagen, save, Screenshot, yes, replace, viel besser, viel besser, Taktak, Status,
mit Status, Index, der Index hat's, achso, ja, A minus M, Amen, push, push, force, in
your face, nein, ich hab kein XFCE, ich kann's normales, die drei ohne, ich hab nur ein
paar XFCE-Programme, so, äh, warum ist das das falsche Bild, das ist das falsche Bild,
ist Browser-Cache, äh, kann man nicht ohne Netmar, hä, was zum, was ist das, was ist
das?
Bin ich, sag mal, bin ich jetzt total verwirrt, nee, was zur, äh, was ist das, was ist das,
hab ich, hab ich schon gepusht, ja, ich hab gepusht, ähm, klar kann ich das überschreiben,
ich hab's doch schon überschrieben, das liegt an meinem Cache, ich hatte das doch gar nicht
hier auf, das liegt überhaupt nicht an meinem Cache, guck mal, ich kann dir beweisen, dass
es nicht an meinem Cache liegt, äh, ok, es liegt an meinem Cache, jetzt hat er's gecheckt,
das ist der Webserver-Cache von GitHub, ja, wahrscheinlich, jetzt haben sie uns aber gebaitet,
jetzt haben sie, ich find das gut, dass wir das KekW-Bild da unten haben, oder, das ist
so random, einfach ein KekW als, als Fernseh, als Fernsehlogo, weißt du, oben ganz seriös
und dann kommt unten das Ding, kannst du deine Streams damit reintun, wo, hier, in den EPG-Guide,
wenn du meine, ja, die stehen da drinnen, wenn du meinen Stream-Kalender in deinem TV-Hat
als EPG importierst, dann geht das, so, Rummel und Rübe, gucken wir uns morgen an, Leute,
nee, gucken wir uns nicht an, weil wir keinen Strike haben wollen und weil ich den Kack
auch gar nicht gucken will, alles klar, wenn man sich das macht, es gibt schon richtig
viel Schrott, oder, ich mein, ich will nichts, ich würde wirklich nichts hiervon gucken
wollen, ich will weder Familie Wöhler auf Mallorca gucken, noch Rummel und Rübe, noch
Bayerns Gartenküche oder die Queen und auch nicht die Eifelpreise, so viel Scheiße, Alter,
das ist ja der Wahnsinn, Musikanten treffen mit der schunkeldicke Backe-Musik, ist ja
eins schlimmer als das andere, rätselhafte Phänomene, das hört sich fast an, wie so,
wie irgendwie so eine komische, wie heißt das, ist das wahr oder erfunden Sendung abklatscht,
schon für Montag das Apple Event, nein, ich kann hier kein Apple Event mehr gucken, die
haben mich schon mal gestrikt, weil ich ein Apple Event geguckt habe auf Twitch, weil
Apple dumm ist, Tipcock, ja genau, weil sie einfach blöd sind, weil sie es nicht checken,
aber gut, es ist Apple, alles klar Leute, so, reicht, ich gehe jetzt essen, wenn es euch
gefällt, könnt ihr das Repost starren und dann sehen wir uns wahrscheinlich, na sicher
morgen früh, morgen früh ist ja Sonntag, da sehen wir uns auf jeden Fall, komm wir hausten
den Krieger, komm wir hausten, was macht der denn, äh, was zum, macht der denn, der guckt
Leute mal Schachspielen zu, ok, äh, nein, das ist jetzt nicht meins, zeigt man da nicht
deinen schön aufgehäumten Desktop, ja sowas mache ich nicht auf Kommando, das muss, äh,
on the fly so spontan passieren, ok, was machen wir denn, wir hausten den Speedrun Event, great,
alles klar, dieser Kanal richtet sich an erwachsene Cacquait, die spielen gerade Pokemon auf dem
Gameboy, Speedrun Event, kann ich sagen, ich habe was für den guten Zweck gemacht und
habe ich heute morgen auch 1-2 Stunden im Hintergrund laufen gehabt, alles klar Leute, wir sehen
uns im nächsten Stream, bis denn, machts gut, CU